the spyer wed around in pain trying
desperately to free itself from the silk
threads that were pinning its eight legs
down Agony coursed through its limbs as
the Venom slowly made its way towards
its abdomen all around it a number of
spiders chattered their Pinchers angrily
and jabbed and poked at its dying body
the spider wasn't sure how much more
pain it could endure before its body
would give out it had done wrong it knew
it had the spider had fallen short of
the Manifesto of the party guidelines
and of the ideals of the fearless leader
it had communicated with the outside
world without permission so it would be
tortured and it would die the spider
just hoped that its death would come
sooner rather than later as the Venom
burned at each of its limbs then all of
a sudden the crowd of spiders around it
parted and the whole web itself began to
shake with heavy footsteps a colossal
spider with gray markings across it its
back towered over the others as it
stalked along the web towards the dying
spider the spider closed its eyes as its
fearless leader spread its mandibles
wide and lunged forward and from a
couple feet above with tears in his eyes
researchers Simon Parker scribbled
Furious notes into his notepad he was
sitting alone in the forest surrounded
by spiderwebs with thousands of tiny
spiders and eight times as many legs
crawling up down in and out of every
tree web and clump of moss in the
clearing it had taken him months to
build up this level of trust with the
arachnids for the longest time none of
them had trusted him in fact many of
them had wanted him dead there had been
numerous assassination attempts as he
had conducted his research but
fortunately for him most of the spiders
in the colony were not particularly
venomous to humans that was until
recently Professor Parker had a mole on
the inside well not a mole but a spider
you get the the idea he had built up a
relationship with the spider as it
seemed disenfranchised by the ideals of
those around it the spider had informed
him just earlier that day that the
arachnids in the colony had made a
deadly breakthrough in their KGB
equivalent unit a toxin so powerful it
could kill the man in one bite this was
all very fascinating for Professor
Parker who watched as his informant was
tortured and eaten right in front of him
it was only one he wrote the closing
line in his notepad that he stopped and
wondered exactly where was this hyper
venomous spider he looked up just in
time a spider with terribly long legs
and shiny purple markings on his back
swung towards him Fang spitting with
Venom he ducked but the spider caught in
his hair and got tangled Professor
Parker leaped to his feet and sprinted
out of the clearing putting his knees
through a number of newly made spider
webs as he went he ran his hands through
his hair flicking and shaking in the
hopes that that the spider had fallen
loose he wasn't proud to be screaming
like a girl all the way out of the
clearing a couple of his colleagues
poked their heads out of the nearby
research lab as he approached
embarrassment got the better of him as
he slowed to a walk and gave them a
courteous wave he couldn't feel the
spider anywhere on his head anymore he
must have gotten away with it that was a
close one Professor Parker went to wipe
the sweat away from his brow but as he
raised his hand he saw a tiny black
spider clinging onto it he had time to
let out one pathetic squeak of surprise
before the arachnid plunged its fangs
into his skin and killed him on the spot
SCP 100006 refers to a spider colony
located in an undisclosed National Park
in the United States of America the
spiders within this Colony vary in
species and size but are united by one
shared goal to promote and uphold the
values of Marxism this colony was
discovered by a group of hikers
traveling through the national park on
on summer break stopping by a stream to
fill up their cantens one of the hikers
noticed a rather complex and extensive
network of webs hanging between some
trees the closer the hiker looked
however the more that they realized that
this was not a normal spider Colony
there were species of spiders here that
one would never normally see roaming
free in the US what was more there
seemed to be something like writing
hanging on the webs but surely that
couldn't be the hiker leaned en Clos and
tried their best to read what was being
said the history of all hitherto
existing Society is the history of class
struggle fortunately the hiker and all
of their friends thought that the
writing in the web was some kind of
prank being played by the national park
they maybe even a very early Halloween
display within a week the SCP Foundation
had arrived and cordon off the area
immediately surrounding the webbing
under the guise of conservation work
investigations began right away into the
exact nature and origins of this
communist group of spiders and the
results were fascinating not only were
their writings resembling Carl Marx's
Communist Manifesto but there were also
a number of webs that had been spun to
resemble the faces of various Park
Rangers who would have been patrolling
the area closer inspection revealed the
existence of a number of rudimentary
tools such as Twigs with pebbles tied to
the tips using silk webbing Fallen
branches surrounding the central web
many of which seemed to show the
markings of tiny axe Cuts where they had
been split from the tree several weeks
of close observation confirmed that the
spiders were indeed creating tiny axes
to cut down branches under the guise of
protecting the central web this was the
first evidence of the spider hostility
towards the human race not only did the
spiders write about the virtues of
Communism but they also seemed intent on
putting it into practice SCP 10006 is
one of only five remaining Marxist
leninist States in the world along with
China Cuba Lao and Vietnam although
admittedly the spider's version of
Communism is very primitive individual
spiders have different roles within the
community each with the intention of
serving the group as a whole some have
the responsibility of maintaining and
fixing any holes within the web whilst
others are given the responsibility of
expanding into new territory some
spiders catch flies other spiders wrap
them and prepare them for consumption
and most interestingly another group
separates the fly's bodies into
individual meal portions and allocates
an equal amount of food to every spider
within the community beyond that the
spiders admittedly do very little they
are spiders after all one bright
researcher by the name of Simon Parker
had the idea one day to hand the spiders
a piece of paper and a small pen like
the kind you find in a bank at the tip
of a little chain immediately the
spiders gathered around the pen and did
their best to coordinate lifting it and
dragging it around the paper
Simon Parker leaned in excited to have
his first communication with another
species but it quickly became apparent
that the spiders were less than excited
to talk to him bis Pig Charming day
after day Simon Parker would sit with
the spiders and do his best to
understand what exactly it was they
wanted he wasn't sure whether they were
incredibly idealistic or simply had a
completely false idea of how powerful he
was what would you like to do today he
would ask them dismantle Western
imperialism with immediate effect before
redistributing wealth equally to the
masses right I can't do much to help
with that it was difficult to have a
conversation with them they were
hyperfixated on their goal and had
little time to talk about niceties or
more pertinent topics like where they
had come from the answer to that
question remains a mystery although
there could be some evidence still to
find from the body at the center of the
web it was Professor Parker who
discovered the body his regular visits
to the web bringing sheets of paper with
him had drawn the attention of a spider
who lived right in the heart of it all
one known as the fearless leader a group
of spiders LED Professor Parker through
the trees towards his Palace in the
middle Professor Parker had to duck and
crawl under a number of dense webs it
didn't take a genius to work out that he
was getting closer and closer to the
origins of this Colony web zero as it
were out of a gap in a tree an enormous
wolf spider crawled out to meet him it
was hairy and gray with strong legs and
a slumping abdomen meekly Professor
Parker offered out the sheet of paper
and Pen to the fearless leader you're
not welcome here we are the proletariat
United in our goals you corrupt with
your foreign ways in corporate greed
Professor Parker tried his best to
explain that he was actually boycotting
Nestle and had done a number of papers
on the virtues of Communism while at
University however he did have to admit
that he had invested fairly heavily in
the stock exchange the fearless leader
bore its fangs at those words and
stomped angrily making its web Sway and
buckle underneath we spiders do what we
must to protect our commune you are not
welcome it was at that point that
Professor Parker saw the body for the
first time it was at his feet shrunken
and dry past the point of smelling
particularly putrid around the body were
a number of small coins bottle caps and
other shiny objects it must have been
the wolf spider's Hall of wealth and
riches so much for equality for all did
you kill this man Professor Parker asked
suddenly feeling his blood running a
little cold was that a set of eight legs
tickling the back of his neck our
actions are our own leave but as
Professor Parker walked away he was
fairly certain he had his answer already
the back of the man's head looked to
have been caved in by some kind of blunt
force impact not something these spiders
would be able to do on their own was
that where their colony had first
started as soon as Professor Parker
reported his findings to the foundation
they launched a careful search of the
surrounding area for any clues as to the
man's identity and within the hour they
were in luck a wallet there wasn't much
inside a couple of quarters and old
receipt so faded it couldn't provide
much information but by some miracle
there was still a driver's license a
match came back right away on the
foundation's database he was a known
political radical expelled from a number
of universities and Fringe political
groups for being a bit too much police
reports pegged him as having gone
missing in the small town in Texas in
1976 that date seemed to match up pretty
well with the state of decomposition on
the body investigations are still
ongoing into the exact nature of this
man's disappearance and what connections
he had if any to the world of reology it
was far too coincidental that a group of
spiders capable of communication and
spouting extreme political rhetoric had
just happened to create a colony onp top
of his corpse but try as Professor
Parker might he couldn't get any
information out of the spiders about the
body in a Godless Society it was evident
that their political views barred them
from giving the corpse spiritual status
but when they talked about the body it
was evidently as close to a religious
sight as they were capable of conceding
only one spider seemed to open up to
Professor Parker the spider had followed
him out to the Colony one evening after
a long and fruitless day arguing about
the benefits of privatizing certain
Industries it swung down in front of him
from a tree and waved him down right on
the edge of the spider's territory
Professor Parker soon discovered that
this spider was a worker spider
responsible for expanding the web little
by little each day until it encompassed
the whole world initially the spider was
just curious as to how long that would
take as in the previous 40 or so years
they had expanded by about 200 M the
fearless leader apparently believed that
the circumference of the world couldn't
be much more than 500 M so they would
soon be in possession of more than half
of the available land laughing Professor
Parker gently explained that it would
take a good while longer before Humanity
felt particularly worried much to his
surprise the spider seemed relieved
evidently torn as to what to say the
spider looked from him to the Colony and
back before writing down its next
sentence on the paper screw Marxism I
just want to try a cheeseburger that was
the start of a peculiar kind of
friendship between the pair every day
the spider would catch him on his way
out and feed him whatever bits of
information it had been privy to on the
inside that was no small task the
spiders had instituted a secret police
similar in hierarchy to the KGB which
kept tight control over the spread of
information within the web Professor
Parker learned that the oldest spiders
in the web had vague memories of being
hatchlings in a bright white room of
being shaken around and transported
somewhere of sharp needles being
injected into eggs of booming literature
being read out on repeat so loud it
would shake the webs beneath their feet
then chaos and fear then Freedom
Professor Parker got a number of small
welts on his body over the next few
weeks little tiny bite marks from
various harmless spiders the worst that
ever happened was he felt a slight itch
for an hour or two before it would go
down and his skin would patch up the
tiny bite marks he would laugh about
these bites with his spider friend as he
brought him little scraps of McDonald's
burgers to sample but the spider was
Gravely serious ious as he chowed down
on his minuscule mouthfuls of beef those
bites are getting stronger rumor is that
they're developing an ultra Venom
something that could take down a human
fearless leader is being humiliated by a
human walking into his territory every
day and knowing that he is powerless to
stop it one day that will change and one
day it did Professor Parker lay on the
grass with foam dribbling out of his
mouth knowing that he was about to die
his small spider companion the friend
that he had spent weeks getting to know
had been tortured and killed because of
him and now it was his turn all he could
do was raise his arm limply and stare at
the tiny arachnid clinging to it the one
whose teeth had plunged into his skin
and killed him the one who had been laid
out on the web and tortured the one whom
he thought had been his friend the
spider hopped down and pulled a pen from
Professor Parker's jacket pocket and
wrote one last message on the back of
his hand Long Live Marxism long live the
spider proletariat death to our enemies
a d-class drag races through the testing
Zone screaming at the top of his lungs
and doing donuts a mime who is also in
the testing chamber stares with
disapproval tapping his foot impatiently
did we mention that the car is made of
spiders yeah this one is going to be a
weird one folks stay tuned for one of
the craziest SCP stories you've ever
heard Emily had always dreamed of taking
a trip to Paris when the opportunity
actually came to visit the city she was
overjoyed she spent her time exploring
art museums tasting the bread and cheese
and walking through the city streets
taking in the sights one of her favorite
things about Paris was all the street
performers as she walked nibbling on a
Pano chakola she delighted in the antics
of jugglers tossing colorful balls into
the air she gasped at the feet of
athleticism and Grace demonstrated by
acrobats and contortionists she giggled
at the Absurd shows put on by puppeteers
and dabed tears from her eyes at the
sound of beautiful songs played and sung
by musicians it became part of her daily
routine one night as Emily was walking
back to her hostel after a long languid
dinner she found herself walking down a
street she had not encountered before
there was no one around except for her
it was a lovely moment of Peace but it
also struck her as a little bit Eerie
and she wished for The Familiar throngs
of people up ahead she spotted the
silhouette of another person and let out
a sigh of relief as she got closer she
could make out the black and white
striped shirt the suspenders the Black
Beret the white face makeup ruged cheeks
and red lips a mime a real classic
French mime she couldn't believe her
luck when he spotted Emily approaching
the MIM began to start a performance he
began with a classic the invisible box
he felt around the walls of the
invisible box looking out with
exaggerated wide eyes and an open mouth
Emily clapped and reached into her bag
for a little bit of money she could use
to tip him after all he was putting on a
performance just for her he deserved it
she walked closer to the mime looking
for a place to put her tip she didn't
see one so she held up her hand offering
the money directly to the mime as he
took notice of how close she was getting
the mime began shaking his head
vigorously eyes wide and insistent she
didn't understand that he was trying to
warn her until it was too late dozens
and dozens of spiders began to crawl
over the mim's face out from inside of
his clothes from his shoes pouring out
over the street and crawling up onto
Emily she tried to brush them off she
tried to run away but no matter how hard
she tried the spiders just kept coming
all she could do was scream in an
attempt to experience a little bit of
Life performance Emily unwittingly came
across SCP
3247 SCP 3247 7 is a humanoid entity
standing at approximately 1.7 m in
height it wears a striped shirt and
suspenders similar to the Garb of a
stereotypical French mime as well as
what appears to be white makeup on its
face and all other Exposed Skin though
these aspects of its appearance seem as
if they should be removable the clothing
and makeup are in fact parts of the
entity's physiology and cannot be
removed from its body this is not the
only unusual aspect of the entity's
physical form though it looks corporeal
and solid The Entity cannot touch or
directly interact with any solid matter
with one particular exception there is a
colony of spiders living on and inside
of SCP
3247 these spiders have officially been
designated as CP
3247 and are highly protective of SCP
3247 if anyone or anything attempts to
approach SCP 32 47 in a threatening
manner the spiders will swarm the
Potential Threat as any Savvy anomalous
activity Enthusiast might have already
gathered these are of course no ordinary
spiders not only do they dwell on and in
an intangible mime but they have a
peculiar response to witnessing a human
being making specific gestures or
pantomiming activities when this occurs
the colony of spiders will form the
shape of an object related to the
gestures which they will then and hold
for up to 3 hours or until given
additional stimuli that prompt a change
in shape while the spider colony is
assembled into shape they will be able
to share some of the given objects
functions in spite of being technically
nothing more than a mass of
well-coordinated
arachnids as for a SCP
3247 it is either incapable of speech or
unwilling to speak instead it
communicates with Foundation staff via
silent miming when it does the spiders
will frequently react to its gestures
becoming effectively living props SCP
3247 does not seem to be especially
thrilled with this likely because miming
is inherently a propess art form and
these spider based props undermine its
artistic Vision otherwise though the
presence of the spiders does not seem to
bother SCP
3247 in order to better understand the
nature of SCP
3247 Foundation staff conducted a series
of tests in each test a declass class
was given a gesture to perform in the
presence of SCP
3247 then the research staff would
record the spider colony's response
during the first test the research staff
ordered D 11424 to attempt to get as
close to SCP 3247 as possible they did
not of course warn him about the spiders
he entered the testing chamber and
approached the mime who was pantomiming
the act of climbing stairs as the mine
pretended to ascend an invisible
staircase and d114 24 grew closer
instances of SCP
3247 emerged to take the shape of a
staircase much to the mim's frustration
SCP 3247 stopped its performance
throwing up its hands in a gesture of
defeat the spiders turned their
attention to D1 11424 and began to swarm
him treating him as a Potential Threat
panicking and Unsure how to communicate
with SCP 3247 while the spiders were
overpowering him d142 for began to wave
frantically at the mime the mime simply
Shrugged giving him a look that said
well what do you want me to do about it
at this point control intervened
instructing D1 11424 to pantomime some
kind of activity fortunately before
turning to a life of crime D1 11424 had
spent several years in a professional
improv troop and was well acquainted
with pantomime his performing instincts
kicked in and he leapt into action he
put a hand to his ear as if listening to
the ringing of a telephone
the spiders stopped their attack
responding immediately to his queue they
formed into the shape of a small table
with an old-fashioned rotary phone on
top the mime rolled its eyes in disdain
at the sight of this prop based
performance but d11 424 was on a roll he
crossed to the phone picked up the
receiver and held it to his ear hello he
asked out of habit he wasn't expecting
to hear a voice on the other line but
then he did or rather he heard the
approximation of a human voice created
by a swarm of anomalous spiders it
sounded a bit like a human voice sped up
high-pitched and squeaky speaking some
sort of gibberish realizing that this
was his moment to escape d142 placed the
phone back in place and promptly left
the testing chamber the spiders remained
in the shape of the rotary phone and the
table for the next 2 hours at which
point they disassembled and returned to
their home on SCP
3247 after his surprisingly creative
work in this first test it was decided
that d11 424 would be the designated
test subject for all future testing with
SCP
3247 provided that additional
complications did not arise though he
wasn't especially fond of spiders d11
424 was more than happy to accept the
assignment not that he had much choice
in the matter still it was definitely a
better deal than getting fed to SCP 682
and it was a nice excuse to use his
improv skills again after a long
retirement during the second test test
d11 424 knew what to expect from SCP
3247 for this test he was told to
pantomime playing tug ofar with an
invisible opponent and an invisible rope
now that he knew his improvisational
scene partner would be a colony of
spiders he was able to enter the testing
chamber with confidence once inside he
began to pantomime pulling on a rope
having that rope tugged away from him by
a strong opponent and struggling to pull
back the spiders reacted right away
arranging themselves in into the shapes
of a long rope one side of which was in
D1 11424 hands as well as a large
humanoid vaguely muscular in shape that
was holding the other side of the Rope
the spiders gave the Rope a sharp tug
causing D1 11424 to lose his balance and
fall over the Rope slipping out of his
grasp aside from some injury to his
pride he was otherwise unharmed during
test number three d11 424 was instructed
to enter the testing chamber and close
his fist while extending the thumb and
index finger in a gesture colloquially
known as finger guns sure enough as soon
as he assumed this position the spiders
assembled into the shape of a handgun
d11 424 was then instructed to pick up
the spider gun and squeeze the place
where the trigger would be if it was a
real gun and not you know spiders a loud
cracking sound was heard when the
d-class squeezed as a spider shot out of
the barrel of the gun at high speed
before smacking into the nearby wall
leaving a small hole in the surface d
424 fired several more times each Shot
firing an individual spider at a pace
that attending researchers described as
faster than a speeding bullet after
firing six rounds of spiders at the wall
d11 424 was instructed to place the
spider gun back on the ground during
test number 76 d11 424 was ordered to
hold his hands together and wiggle four
fingers on each hand effectively
pantomiming a spider the research team
was curious to see what the spiders
would do when presen presented with a
shape that matched their usual
unassembled form SCP 3247 who generally
did not react much to the experiments on
its spiders began shaking its head in
mild disappointment as approximately 640
spiders emerged from its body dividing
themselves into groups of eight each
group of eight spiders then joined to
form one large spider leaving eight
spiders these eight then split into
pairs who joined together into one
larger spider and so on and so forth
until there was one single giant spider
made from the hundreds of smaller
spiders at this point D1 11424 followed
his heart jumping onto the mega spider's
back and riding it like a bull at the
rodeo as the spider bucked and ran back
and forth across the room according to
official transcripts D 11424 yelled
Yeehaw throughout this part of the test
until the head researcher ordered him to
climb down from the spider and exit the
room he was reprimanded for his behavior
and warned that if he acted without
approval again he would be taken off the
project and reassigned to a much less
enjoyable position as one of the
designated eyes on SCP 173 D1 11424
immediately agreed to comply with future
instructions during test number 133 d11
424 was sent into the testing chamber
and told to Shadowbox he danced back and
forth across the cell doing his best
Sylvester Salone impression and throwing
punches in the general direction of the
spiders in response approximately 3,000
spiders poured out of SCP
3247 assembling into the shadowy shape
of a boxer and began to attack d11 424
the mass of spiders conducted itself at
the level of a professional boxer
dodging d142 for's hits before coming
back at him with a jab cross lead
uppercut and rear uppercut before he
could defend himself d11 424 fell to the
ground unconscious and guards were
forced to interrupt the test in order to
remove him from the room and take him to
the infirmary for medical treatment
after taking some time to recuperate d11
424 returned to testing with SCP
3247 he was instructed to mine steering
a wheel such as that of a car
immediately a number of spiders
previously unseen during testing emerged
from SCP
3247 arranging themselves into the shape
of a sedan d11 424 was then commanded to
climb inside of the spider car and see
if he could start it he refused
insisting I'm not getting in a spider
car are you nuts when pressed by control
to comply with orders he made a rude
hand gesture I'll let you guess what
that was the spiders began to scramble
to reassemble themselves in response to
the changed gesture prompting control to
stop the test early to spare the
researchers sensibilities with strict
guidelines to avoid inappropriate or
violent gestures d11 424 was sent back
into the testing chamber with
instruction to try out a variety of
animal inspired gestures in Rapid
success session he formed one hand into
a fist and made a peace sign with the
other hand putting them together to make
a snail as he made his hand snail crawl
through the air the spiders crawled onto
the floor and assembled into the shape
of a snail in front of d11 424 though
the spiders moved quickly at their usual
scuttling Pace once they formed into the
snail they slowed to a gradual creep
d144 noted a shiny slimy Trail left
behind on the floor as the spider snail
moved he was was asked to consider
touching it but refused simply stating
ew no next he took his hands and formed
the shape of a wolf's head howling at
the moon the research staff were curious
to see if the spiders would form a
wolf's head or the animal's entire body
they got their answer as the spider
swarmed and shifted forming the shape of
a full-sized gray wolf the wolf padded
back and forth across the room before
sitting down lifting its head and
emitting an audible howl that sounded
almost indistinguishable from the real
thing thing next D 11424 crossed his
thumbs over each other fluttering hands
like a pair of wings the spiders
separated into smaller groups and came
together to form butterflies similar in
size to a monarch these spider
butterflies began to Flat their wings
and much to d11 424 surprise they took
flight and swirled through the air
around him the d-class was so moved by
the beautiful sight that he shed a
single tear which he promptly wiped away
out of embarrassment control then
prompted him to try the next animal
gesture D1 11424 used his hands to form
the shape of a rabbit several of the
spiders crawled away returning to SCP
3247 and the remaining spiders took on
the form of a rabbit the spider rabbit
hopped realistically around the room
twitching its ears and tail at this
point D1 11424 was instructed to offer
the spider rabbit a carrot he produced a
carrot from his pocket holding it out in
front of him the spider rabbit hopped
over to him and one Crunch at a time
began to eat the carrot until none
remained d11 424 appeared shaken up and
asked to leave the testing chamber as he
followed all of his instructions this
request was granted when he exited the
chamber all he would say was where the
hell did the carrot go it doesn't have a
stomach it doesn't have a mouth where
did it go SCP 3247 is kept in an
isolated chamber located in the arachnid
wing of area 12 it does not appear to
require food or rest but it has been
provided with a television and a
collection of silent films for morale
purposes instances of SCP 3247 are fed
via a fully automated system that
dispenses 20 G of live crickets every
week should a Containment Breach occur
staff have been instructed to find a way
to make escaped spiders take on the
shape that renders them motionless then
simply pick the spider cluster up and
place it back inside of the cell it is
unlikely that the foundation will ever
get an explanation for where the
intangible mime and his Mery band of
spider performers originated from but
one thing is clear they won't be
performing in public again anytime soon
there's been a strange phenomenon
sweeping Central Germany while the true
extent of its influence is still unknown
it seems to have been going on for quite
some time now usually in irregular
intervals if you were to head down to
any of the towns within the affected
region for a visit the chances of you
noticing anything out of the ordinary
would still be rather low but then again
if you're in the wrong place at the
wrong time it's entirely possible you
could witness An Occurrence of SCP
3023 every arachnophobes worst nightmare
one terrifying incident happened at a
baseball game held during the height of
the Summer with the scorching Sun
hanging high above a stadium packed with
eager fans the home team was neck and
neck with their longtime Rivals from the
next town over as the players took to
the field after a change over everything
hung in the balance the home team's
coach had made a bold change sending out
a new baseman a young man named jenck
denke he was a rookie untested but the
team's strongest veterans had been doing
their best through the whole first half
of the game and still the scores were
almost tied and so janx stepped up to
the base unaware that making the next
catch would change his life forever the
crowd was silent the tensions flattening
their cheers and chants to a low murmur
as the rival's heaviest hitter stepped
up to the bat he was a behemoth arms
twice the size of the baseball bat he
carried over his broad shoulder striding
up with confidence as he ready to swing
watching and waiting a bead of sweat
rolled down janik's forehead dropping
down the bridge of his nose he couldn't
tell which was making him sweat more the
heat of the Sun or his own nerves his
teammate at the pitcher's mound lifted a
leg the baseball in hand if he gripped
the ball any any tighter his fingernails
might have splintered and got lodged in
the white synthetic leather wrapped
around it JX stared not even bothering
to wipe away the drops of sweat in his
eyes as his teammate's throwing arm
reeled back and hurled the ball forward
it felt like time itself had slowed down
the Rival team's batter swatted the
baseball out of the air with an earth
shattering crack that sent the ball
speeding through the air jenck dashed to
catch it his mitt outstretched the ball
was Greening back down to earth like a
white and red meteorite almost moving
fast enough to burn up on re-entry as it
hurled through the atmosphere Janet
could feel his heart rattling against
his rib cage as every instinct told him
he'd never make that fateful catch in a
final Act of desperation he leaped off
the ground with every ounce of strength
and all around him the crowd exploded
with the thunderous sounds of overjoyed
Applause the mighty force of the weighty
cork ball was like catching a punch in
midair the Tremors of the impct attack
Rippling down jick's arm he felt that
first before realizing that the ball was
now lodged securely in his hand he'd
done it he' made the catch the batter
was out but before he could even react
in celebration it happened his arm
recovered from the initial shock of the
catch just in time to feel the Lightning
Fast flurry of small legs scuttling over
his skin barely able to catch his breath
the last thing jenck saw was something
that used to be the baseball hurriedly
crawling up his chest towards his neck
from a distance his teammates the fans
and the audience only saw him drop to
the turf flailing his arms trying to
brush off something crawling over him as
it attacked and killed the young baseman
in what otherwise would have been the
proudest moment of his life while that
might have been the first time anything
like that had ever happened it certainly
wouldn't be the last now have you ever
passed by an abandoned building and felt
an urge to look around inside of course
a lot of us have but most of of us are
smart enough to resist the urge but on
the very rare times you and your friends
have worked up the courage to explore
somewhere like this you've probably
never found anything all that
interesting then again you might want to
think twice before sneaking past those
keep out and condemn signs Maxi and Iva
learned that lesson the hard way when
they gained access to an abandoned
office block maybe they were trying
their hand at making a Blair Witch
Project Style amateur found footage
movie or could have been dabbling in
some Urban exploration best case there
might have been a few places of office
furniture left behind by the building's
previous occupants something that the
removal company forgot to take when the
place was cleared out the pair of them
could have just helped themselves after
all they needed a new folding chair for
their apartment and there was one just
sitting
there trembling through her stifled
tears iva's phone was shuddering in her
hand the office had been dark but she
was certain the shadowy shape that had
taken Maxi didn't belong to a human
being clamping her hand over her mouth
to silence her terrified breaths she
peered out from under the desk pointing
her phone's camera wherever she looked
as it recorded Iva could hear the loud
tapping of several metal legs moving
hurriedly around the empty office the
noise would pause at irregular intervals
every time it stopped she thought no
prayed that the creature was gone but
just as Iva went to look she would hear
the same sound quick scampering steps
the kind of movements that feel
unnatural to look at that are only
possible for things with eight legs
perhaps that made it worse the creature
didn't shriek or scream or breathe like
you'd expect of some awful monster in a
horror movie but then again how could it
it had been a chair when Maxi had walked
up to it nothing more than an ordinary
folding chair the patter of metal
footsteps stopped again this time for
longer it had to be gone now she thought
she gave it another few seconds just to
make sure the silence wasn't broken
again crawling out from under the desk
her phone still in her hand Iva allowed
herself to breathe a tentative sigh only
for that sigh to become a scream as it
lunged at her the chair's seat and back
now the body and Ma of an angry arachnid
monster as Iva screamed her phone caught
the whole gruesome sight on camera you
might be starting to see a pattern
emerging here but there's yet another
twist in this multi-legged tail what if
these occurrences weren't just random
incidents sure they might fall into the
freak of nature category like so many
other anomalous incidents but while it's
unclear exactly how these particular
anomalies come about could it be
possible that something or someone is
creating them on purpose mobile task
force Alpha 21 were already on the scene
in the aftermath of the latest incursion
the elite Foundation Strike Team had
eliminated the threat luckily it had
started Life as a phone meaning they
were able to remotely destroy it causing
its electronic components to detonate
not before it had killed two Foundation
Personnel though naturally now came the
cleanup operation Gathering up evidence
leaving no trace of what had happened
the SCP Foundation still had little clue
as to what exactly caused instances of
this nature a phenomenon they had now
designated as SCP 3023 all they had to
go on was a handful of cases and footage
recovered from a cell phone that had
belonged to an Urban Explorer who' met
an untimely end at the jaws of a folding
chair but speaking of footage something
unusual had been caught by a security
camera a few days before the latest SCP
3023 incident the security footage
showed a man breaking into an office
where the latest 3023 instance the
telephone had been found as he picked up
the phone in question this individual's
jaw appeared to a naturally split open
horizontally allowing four dark tongue
likee appendages to emerge emerge these
appendages rubbed the phone for over
half a minute before retracting the man
then returned the phone to its original
place and promptly left the office
thanks to further investigations
conducted by the foundation's forensic
experts this unknown individual was
identified as Mr SAR the owner of a
local restaurant naturally MTF Alpha 21
moved in to apprehend the suspect the
only real lead as to what has been
causing the multiple instances of SCP
3023 to begin occurring in Germany
however when SAR was eventually detained
he showed next to no sign of any
anomalies in his body he claimed to have
no memory of the events depicted in the
security footage had never encountered
any previous SCP 3023 instance and
seemed to possess no knowledge of the
strange properties he exhibited on
camera nonetheless the SCP Foundation
was forced to detain Mr SAR although he
never displayed any anomalous Behavior
ever again now you might be forgiven for
thinking that with with Sor held in
Foundation custody everyone could
breathe a sire of relief but sadly for
any arachnophobes watching at home new
instances of SCP 3023 kept cropping up
in even stranger and more horrific
fashion than ever before imagine you had
a headache and we're talking about a
real killer here one of those power
drill to the frontal lobe migraines
maybe you'd spend too much time glued to
a computer screen at work and all that
blue light from your monitor scrambled
your gray matter or perhaps last night
was a prettyy wild one and after a few
too many drinks you were left feeling
hung over the next morning what's your
go-to response in that situation
obviously you can call in sick to work
then go to your medicine cabinet or an
over-the-counter Pharmacy and grab some
basic painkillers paracetamol aspirin
ibuprofen all the things that we trust
to make us feel better not to make
things even worse to Patrick this
started as one of the most normal things
in the world world like you or I his
immediate response to finding himself
suffering from a raging headache was to
grab a gelatin capsule of ibuprofen as
casually and unsuspectingly as anyone
would he took the pill in hopes of
quickly relieving his pain and carrying
on with his day probably even chasing it
down with a quick glass of water only
unbeknownst and unseen to Patrick
something happened the moment that
Ibuprofen capsule passed through his
lips and went towards his throat
something that stopped it from fully
going down his throat in fact much like
the baseball the folding chair the phone
and who knows how many other unrecorded
incidents the pill had sprouted eight
spider-like legs at first it started as
a gentle cough like you'd expect when a
capsule gets lodged in your throat
grabbing a tissue Patrick gave a few
grunting attempts at clearing his Airway
there was definitely something in there
that almost felt like it was scratching
not the kind of scratch at the back of
the throat brought on by some allergies
the kind of scratching that caused
Patrick to cough up blood when he put a
tissue to his mouth the kind of
scratching that he could feel moving
crawling around his windpipe perhaps if
he had more time Patrick could have
raced to the hospital and had whatever
was clawing its way around his throat
removed safely with that free European
health care unfortunately the thing that
the capsule had turned into just as he
swallowed it wasn't that kind racked
with unimaginable pain Patrick was
writhing and spluttering controllably
his mouth filled with more bile and
blood than saliva at that point the
scratching was moving and not down
towards his esophagus towards his
stomach it was going outwards burrowing
through the insides of his neck until it
reached his spinal cord by that time the
little ibuprofen capsule sized instance
of SCP 3023 came crawling out from the
back of his neck Patrick was already
dead let's say you were aware of this of
all these strange happenings seemingly
ordinary everyday objects turning into
angry aggressive spiders obviously the
foundation might want to have a little
chat with you about how you came across
such information but for the sake of
argument imagine you did know you might
think the smart idea would be to leave
after all as CP 3023 instances are only
known to occur in a specific region of
Central Germany neatly situated in the
middle of leig and dor so you might
think that it's time to up sticks and
leave that area maybe even leave Germany
altogether just hop in your car and
drive to safety if only it were that
easy a family of four was cruising down
the Autobon in an SUV just another car
on the packed Highway exhausted after
hours on the road Mato and Nina sat
quietly up front making sure they didn't
wake their son and daughter both asleep
in the rear passenger seats the car was
picking up speed about to pass 70 mph as
it gradually carried them home although
it wasn't going to get them all the way
back the Screech of twisting metal woke
both sleeping kids up screaming their
parents equally shocked at the sudden
noise the car lurched and buckled like
something had collided with it but this
was no ordinary traffic accident without
any Rhyme or Reason the front of their
SUV warped itself into the distinctive
shape of a sephila thorax while the rear
turned into what looked like an abdomen
as the car shifted and reshaped around
them the grinding of metal as Auto Parts
became huge metal legs Mato Nina and
their children were still trapped inside
never to make it out but the creepy
crawly Carnage wasn't just contained
inside the car the newly born ARA knit
Abomination hurdled its way down the
Autobon managing to maintain its speed
other drivers swerved and slammed on
their brakes to avoid hitting the
creature they couldn't even believe was
scuttling hurriedly along the highway
unfortunately this led them to careening
into other cars smashing head first into
a pileup that claimed the lives of 41
people not that the SCP Foundation would
ever admit it with one of their
facilities only 250 M away they were
quick to dispatch an air strike to deal
with the spidery SUV once it became
clear that mobile task force Alpha 21
couldn't contain it across the board
anything capable of sprouting four pairs
of spinny legs and crawling towards you
with the intent to kill tends to rack up
quite the body count but dealing with
bodies are some people's business that
was the case for Lucas a newly qualified
coroner after passing years of training
he was working with the local police
department performing autopsies and
examining bodies to help them with their
investigations sure it may not have been
the most glamorous profession but Lucas
could sleep soundly knowing that he'd
never get hurt by a dead body a John Doe
a body that hadn't yet been identified
had just been brought in after police
had found him on the side of the road
Lucas thoroughly washed his hands put on
his gloves and scrubs along with the
rest of the autopsy team team he'd sat
in on at least a dozen of these
procedures studied the relevant process
and techniques everything had prepared
him for the job of figuring out how
someone had died but not even the most
experienced medical examiner could be
prepared for what happened next taking
the lead Lucas began by making the
primary incision into the cadaver's
chest it always reminded him of a
particular scene in the thing where a
character's stomach opened up and became
a ma of frightening teeth revealing them
to be the shape-shifting alien that
thought was quickly shaken away when
suddenly to Lucas's surprise the body
lurched violently on the examining table
not everyone expects dead bodies to be
able to move and while it might be rare
it's also not impossible any number of
things can cause someone's remains to
move after death muscles atrophying or
spasming the body filling up with gas as
it breaks down of course any coroner
would expect these movements to have
subsided by the time someone reaches the
autopsy room caught off guard by the
sudden violent movement Lucas stepped
away dropping his scalpel his panting
breath warmed his face beneath his
surgical mask as he stared for a moment
waiting to see if the body moved again
certain it would be still now Lucas
wrote the spooky incident off just as a
muscle spasm and leaned over to retrieve
his scalpel but while he was crouching
he noticed something strange it almost
looked as if there were a pair of
protrusions poking out from under the
Dead Man's skin walk looking around the
other side of the table Lucas found two
more similar lumps at the body's abdomen
almost as if something was inside ready
to force its way out without warning the
John do suddenly moved again on the
examining table only this time it didn't
stop Lucas couldn't believe his eyes the
man's face was still frozen in the same
dead expression but his arms and legs
were thrashing and writhing around as if
he was somehow still alive four extra
limbs suddenly burst from the the sides
of the kadab and the now eight-legged
creature reared itself up leaping
towards a member of the autopsy team it
scuttled and skittered around on its new
appendages while Lucas watched in horror
blood curdling screams filled the
autopsy room as he bolted for the door
Lucas raced down the corridor the
coroner dared not looking behind him
while sprinting through the city
Mortuary behind him he could hear the
thuing of the spider's multiple limbs
right at his heels out of the corner of
his eyes right on the edge of his
peripheral vision he could see the
massive legs scuttling towards him maybe
he would get out run all the way to
safety before the spider was upon him
but how can you hope to outrun something
with eight legs when you only have two
the most important thing to remember is
that while any unsuspecting inanimate
object near you might suddenly decide to
become an angry spider the chances of it
happening are very very low but
especially if you happen to be in
central Germany those chances are never
zero either the creature let out an un
mistakable squeal of Rage as stimulus y
835 took effect Dr Christensen pressed
his face up against the glass eager to
see the results it had to work this time
it simply had to he was certain that
this attempt would make all the other
failures worth it and he'd once again
Pro the foundation's faith in him to be
well placed SCP 5683 shrieked a loud
insect-like sound that would have
normally made the blood run cold of
anyone that hurt it but to Dr
Christensen it was like music a
monster's dying Fanfare to mark his
success soon he'd be the researcher who
neutralized not one but two tenacious
highly adaptable anomalies the senior
researcher could feel his heart racing
as the deadly giant spider started to
Twitch then burst into two identical
entities the pair of arachnid anomalies
had reacted much like the results of the
tissue sample tests conducted earlier
dividing into two separate organisms
Christensen held his breath the tissue
samples had destroyed each other
attacking and injecting the other with
lethal doses of Venom surely he reasoned
duplicating SCP 5683 into two would have
the same result his heart sank as he
watched one of the spider creatures the
duplicate perish almost immediately as
it often did when presented with human
prey SCP 5683 attacked using its
mandibles and impaled its copy with its
front legs to pin it in place the Clone
had bitten back with Dr Christensen
already knowing that would have granted
SCP 5683 an immunity to its own Venom
its powers of adaptation were fiercely
frustratingly efficient and nothing
demonstrated this more than the intense
reaction from the man tasked with
destroying it do Christensen hurled the
nearest object a coffee mug at a glass
window of the observation room
overlooking the test chamber he pounded
his fist against the glass hardly with
the required Force to cause damage but
enough to send pain shooting down
christensen's wrist which then nestled
in his forearm a reminder that the
experiment like the others had failed
why can't I destroy you he muttered
through clenched teeth looking with
hatred at the enormous spider in the
chamber below the directive had reached
him the day immediately after New Year's
Day 2020 and straight from a member of
the 05 Council no less their message
expressed how impressed the council was
with Dr christensen's success with the
Doomsday Clock project and how favorably
his name had been mentioned in Council
meetings this voted well for the
ambitious Foundation doctor he'd been
hoping to snag the director position at
site 04 now that director Bray had
retired but there was one more test from
the 05 Council they wanted Dr
Christensen to use the knowledge
garnered during his previous success to
solve the SCP
5683 problem if he could successfully
complete that assignment it would be his
ticket to being promoted with the comfy
role of site director and all its perks
in mind Dr Christensen accepted the
assignment from the council to deal with
SCP
5683 SCP 5683 was quite the Beast not an
anomaly for those with intense
arachnophobia
the huge spider-like organism was
extremely hostile towards humans and had
to be kept in a constant state of
medical sedation otherwise it would
relentlessly attempt to breach
containment and Slaughter any and all
Personnel in its path what had made SCP
5683 such a problem for the foundation
was the creature's ability to rapidly
regenerate damage as well as modify its
own body in reaction to threats much
like a certain particularly hardto
destroy reptile the The spider-like
Entity could adapt itself to become more
resistant to any danger posed to it and
of course this meant that the foundation
needed this dangerous creature
eradicated the frequent containment
breaches and sheer number of casualties
caused by the arachnid anomaly were
significant enough to cause an
increasing drain on the SCP foundation's
resources so with a termination order
coming from the very top the 05 Council
themselves Dr Christensen was tasked
with overseeing the neutralization
of SCP
5683 during an initial deliberation Dr
Christensen met with researcher miles
and Hall Junior researchers Silva and
security Chief ad to discuss earlier
attempts to terminate SCP
5683 the new head of the termination
project was perturbed to learn that the
research team had little in the way of
useful information to offer beyond what
the foundation already knew about the
creature but Christensen decided some
basic stress testing would would at
least be a start after a successful
tissue sample test where in some of SCP
5683 genetic material was incinerated Dr
Christensen tried to Simply destroy the
spider with fire an understandable
response to say the least however
exposing SCP 5683 to temperatures of
850° C for just 30 seconds didn't quite
yield the easy Victory he had hoped for
the arachnid thrashed about and
screeched in reaction to the Heat only
to rapidly develop a form of armor
plating covering its entire body the
armor was comprised of an unknown
unidentifiable substance but it was
enough to prevent SCP 5683 from
combusting reconvening with the rest of
the team Dr Christensen hid his pride
assuring everyone he was just trying to
establish a baseline during the previous
test of course he hadn't believed that
terminating SCP 5683 with fire would be
a success or so he claimed hiding how
much he longed for an easy solution so
he could snatch up the vacant sight 04
director position but to ensure the
others Christianson explained that he'd
requisition some anomalous materials
from the 05 Council that they'd be using
in their next termination attempts
nothing that was anomalous enough to
require containment but toxic enough
that they presented a few options for
destroying SCP
5683 uh just for logging purposes sir
may I inquire about the specific
substances where shipping in junior
researcher Sylvia had asked of course
y220 y 835 and y43 Dr Christensen
quickly recounted them all from memory
I'm told they should be arriving within
the week I expect each would be enough
to do the job but it's best to hedge our
bets the spider doesn't compare to the
lizard I'll tell you that Junior
researcher Silva seemed to take an
interest in what Dr Christensen had just
alluded to his previous work with the
lizard he probed further about it and
Christian gave a solemn response the
aspiring Foundation doctor recalled an
incident from a few years earlier during
his experimentation with SCP 682 some of
the methods Dr Christensen had opted to
employ in an attempt to destroy the hard
to destroy reptile had led to a severe
Containment Breach when describing it he
used the word unpleasant perhaps out of
guilt at how many personnel had lost
their lives due to his actions brushing
the topic aside he assured the team to
get on with testing the new anomalous
stimuli on SCP
5683 stimulus y220 initially showed some
promise during a tissue sample test it
successfully converted part of SCP 5683
into glass which then violently exploded
leaving nothing behind but attempts to
use it to neutralize the creature itself
quickly quashed those promising results
within 9 seconds of being exposed to
stimulus y220 SCP 5683 is body rapidly
turned to glass around 80% of its arach
Mass proceeded to explode shattering in
all directions sending clear shards
showering over the testing chamber as he
watched doct christens send allowed
himself to believe that this was mission
accomplished that he'd successfully
terminated as SCP
5683 but his celebration was premature
the spider quickly began reconstituting
itself its body regenerating within the
space of 30 seconds after testing with
both stimuli y220 and Y 835 Dr
christensen's frustration seemed to be
increasing with each failed attempt he
knew his promotion was Within Reach and
as far as he could remember he done good
work with damaging SCP 682 why should
eradicating this anomalous spider be any
different however it was a test with
stimulus y 436 that enraged the
ambitious doctor expecting the anomalous
stimulant to turn as CP 5683 into a fine
Mist Christensen watched as the
creature's body vanished literally VAP
vaporizing changing states of matter to
little more than water in the air
suddenly every light in the facility
powered off plunging the testing chamber
into darkness when the lights came back
on SCP 5683 was standing on all eight
legs right where it had been missed only
3 seconds earlier the research team had
gathered for another mediation and Dr
christensen's anger still hadn't
subsided he kicked a chair to emphasize
his frustration alarming Junior
researcher Silva who urged him to to
calm down after eventually cooling his
temper Christensen made an announcement
that caused even greater concern to
spread amongst the team I'm
requisitioning y910 researcher halls and
researcher miles objected trying to get
Dr Christensen to realize that the
course of this action was excessive
Overkill even but Christensen
disregarded them standing by his latest
method for terminating SCP
5683 the global occult Coalition had
previously used y910 to poison Gods he
felt sure that it would work on one
anomalous giant spider his time was
running short Dr Christensen was aware
that any day now the 05 Council would be
appointing a replacement director of
site 04 and he wanted that promotion and
he didn't seem to care what Corners he
cut and what risks he took to get there
even if it meant endangering his
research Personnel Dr Christensen
declared that in order to save time he
would be bypassing tissue samples to T
for termination attempts the longer it
took to terminate the anomalous arachnid
the more his window of opportunity
closed and the further the director
position slipped from his fingertips
accepting full responsibility for The
Reckless decision and anything that
might go wrong doctor Christensen wanted
to use stimulus y910 directly on SCP
5683 he urged the research team to make
the necessary preparations unaware of
what his decision would lead to and the
chaos it had already caused the test was
catastrophic so much so that it caused a
Containment Breach with SCP 5683 loose
and scuttling about the facility on its
multiple legs Dr Christensen and Junior
researcher Silva were forced to rush to
the secure bunker on site for safety
Christensen was in a state of panic
until he noticed something and not for
the first time either he'd been
detecting a foul smell whenever he
conducted the meetings to discuss
termination options but the other
members of the search team had quickly
explained it was nothing more than
repeated accidents in the cafeteria but
here was the stench again worse than
ever yet Junior researcher Silva brushed
it off again stating that SCP 5683 must
have gotten into the facility's reactor
the junior researcher quickly became
inconsolable stating that the whole
situation was his fault Dr Christensen
interjected demanding to know how it was
and what Silva had done to cause the
situation he replied that said it was
his duty to oppose ill-advised actions
and when Christensen had declared his
intention to use y910 the Junior
researcher hadn't opposed him Shifting
the blame from himself onto his
subordinate Dr Christensen chastised
Silva over how many personnel had died
because of the junior researchers
refusal to do his job ignoring that it
was christensen's own Ambitions that had
led to the current chaos refusing to be
made a scapegoat Dr Christensen vowed to
pin the full culpability for SCP 5683
Containment Breach onto Junior
researcher Silva saying he tell the 05
Council the so-called truth about what
had happened but Silva pointed out that
there wasn't much of a likelihood that
the bunker would survive the reactor
overloading he urged the ambitious
Foundation doctor to admit some
responsibility of his own for what had
happened but Christensen refused
suddenly there came a thunderous banging
at the bunker door a debilitating Pang
of fear struck Dr Christensen caus
causing him to scream and Retreat from
the entrance yelling no and please as if
he was pleading with the universe itself
to spare him from the spider Junior
researcher Silva walked over to the
bunker door just as strong arachnid legs
tore the heavy steel bulkhead off its
hinges like it was made of little more
than wet paper there was SCP
5683 the enormous spider skittering Into
the Bunker screeching all the while
Silva had put himself between SCP 5683
and the amb ious Foundation doctor whose
hunger for a promotion had led to all
this Carnage the junior researcher
announced his Noble intention to
sacrifice himself occupying the creature
while urging Christensen to run the
doctor shoved Silva towards the spider
and prepared to run then all of a sudden
SCP 5683 vanished Junior researcher
Silva told Dr Christensen he was
disappointed before researcher miles
researcher Hall and security Chief ad
all entered the bunker through the torn
open hole where the door had been
Christensen questioned where SCP 5683
had gone to which Silva explained there
was little reason to keep a dummy around
once it had served its purpose as a
substitute you mentioned you worked with
a lizard sir the junior researcher
recounted that there was a Containment
Breach if you don't terribly mind me
asking how did you escape that situation
it seemed quite lethal didn't it afraid
and Confused Dr Christian s asked where
he was Hall and Miles urged him not to
ask questions he already knew the answer
to Silva explained who they all were a
jury specifically Dr christensen's jury
and according to them the ambitious
doctor had disgraced himself again
Christensen had been there for a long
time a considerably long time reliving
the same events over and over again with
SCP 5683 acting as a substitute ude for
SCP 682 it was the same situation he'd
made the same decisions the same
mistakes and it had cost lives now Dr
Christensen was trapped in an endless
loop Penance for the casualties that had
occurred at his hands all in the pursuit
of his own selfish personal gain he
asked the jury how long he'd be stuck
there a question Silva responded to with
until you take responsibility sir
immediately Dr Christensen tried to
admit that this all had been his fault
but he didn't mean it not really he
hadn't accepted blame he just wanted a
quick and easy way out of the loop and
the jury of his deceased Personnel knew
it Christensen ran for the door in the
hopes of escaping his fate futile as his
chances were a black iron chain appeared
from around the corner and wrapped
itself around the overambitious doctor's
throat ignorant of his pleas for
forgiveness saying he was sorry wouldn't
bring back the people who died in
service of his aspirations to becoming a
site director the chain dragged Dr
Christensen through the facility at such
a speed that he collided with every wall
and every corner as he turned sharply
being pulled along the floor but that
and the walls quickly crumbled away
revealing a sight that made Dr
Christensen start screaming that it
wasn't his fault and he never really
stopped what followed involved a great
deal of blood and fire once it was over
it left behind the same awful stench the
doctor had smelled before and he'd soon
be smelling it again too as the cycle
repeated itself the directive had come
straight from a member of the 05 Council
they were impressed with Dr Christenson
and the ambitious Foundation doctor had
been hoping to snag a director position
at site 04 but there was one final test
for Dr Christensen to solve the SCP
5683 problem we've all heard of the lead
Zeppelin song Stairway to Heaven a title
that invokes the image of a Stairway
leading up to a land of Peace in
Paradise but where else could a Stairway
lead to a Dusty Attic full of old photo
albums to the upper level of a mall
where the movie theater and frozen
yogurt shop are neatly situated perhaps
it leads to a rooftop with a beautiful
view or maybe just maybe a staircase
could lead you to SCP
2427 SCP 2427 appropriately nicknamed a
thing full of stuff is an extra
dimensional area filled with a variety
of unusual and anomalous objects SCP
2427 can be accessed by way of a broken
Stone staircase located in rural Ohio
according to local Legend carrying a
sprig of Hemlock up the broken stairs
will allow a person to emerge into a
mysterious grass clearing that appears
to be in a forest somewhere in the
United States no matter what time a
person ascends the staircase the solar
time in the clearing will always be 2:00
p.m. you know how people say it's 5:00
somewhere well it's 2:00 somewhere too
and that somewhere is here the pocket
Dimension that is SCP 2427 is thought to
have been a holding area for weapons
prisoners and artifacts belonging to an
ancient cult known as the Brazen heart
little is known about this relatively
obscure cult other than the fact that
that they worship the Demonic entity
molok a known Enthusiast of violent
human sacrifice and were previously
thought to have been eradicated during
the Spanish Inquisition the existence of
SCP 2427 suggests that they're very much
not eradicated and are still active they
refer to these holding areas as addicts
and though no confirmed members of the
Brazen heart have been contacted it is
considered possible that there are at
least a handful of other addicts hidden
around around the world the foundation
has identified seven anomalous objects
inside of SCP 2427 so far each strange
in its own beautiful though often
terrible way like snowflakes if they
were capable of killing or Ming you the
first object in SCP 2427 AKA SCP
24271 is a seemingly normal fire hydrant
however if you think there's anything
normal about the items found here then
you haven't been paying attention the
hydrant is made out of lead and when
opened it expels high levels of ionized
radiation no specific measurements of
the radiation have been taken yet but it
is definitely hazardous to human health
one unfortunate member of d-class
personnel has proven that it is a high
enough level to melt human flesh sorry
about your face Dave the hydron is
currently contained within an
electrified perimeter and is not to be
opened under any circumstances to
prevent any further flesh melting the
the last thing we need is another Dave
incident the second object contained
with an SCP 2427 or scp4 27-2 is not
actually an object at all it's a
building only on number two and we're
already throwing curveballs at you trust
no one surprises lurk around every
corner this particular building
resembles a large multi-storage
sanitarium built in the
1860s though it is clear from the
outside that the building has or should
have multiple storage
the inside is a different matter past
the building's front doors is a nonukan
space consisting of a single floor and
three sparsely decorated rooms with one
Central foyer the first room is the
holding place for SCP 2427-3 the second
contains SCP
24274 and the third room contains
nothing except scattered religious
documents bottled water and a selection
of canned food no unauthorized staff are
permitted to enter the building buing in
order to minimize complications or
potential employee casualties the first
two anomalies on this list are hardly
even strange by a CP Foundation
standards sure the hydron can melt your
face and the building defies the laws of
physics and space but that's just a
regular Tuesday around these
parts been there seen that what else you
got well SCP 2427-3 is where things
really get strange if you're wandering
through the bowels of scp2 4 27-2 when
you make a wrong turn into the first
room you will find yourself face to face
with a startling sight this entity is a
combination of electronic circuitry a
cow's digestive tract the hairless head
of a human man a hat rack several
lengths of garden hose and an
unidentified crystalline structure this
creature is extraordinarily fast and
strong exhibiting carnivorous Tendencies
and a very strong point of view on the
world around it lucky for us it is
capable of speech and is able to tell us
just what it thinks though this
monstrosity doesn't have much of a right
to pass judgment on anyone cow intestine
body and all it has expressed a violent
hatred of all life that it considers
impure anyone who encounters SCP 2427-3
experiences an overwhelming desire to
submit themselves for judgment allowing
the creature to determine their purity
there is a rumor that if one is judged
to be pure pure they will have a wish
granted if they are deemed impure
however they will be devoured alive if
you're tempted to introduce yourself to
the creature your odds are not
especially great the creature has not
encountered a single pure being yet in
order to protect the foundation staff
working in its vicinity the entrance to
SCP 2427-3 room has been sealed off with
a reinforced steel door and the windows
have been paved over with concrete armed
guards are watching ing the entrance at
all times the creature must be fed one
live goat per day in order to keep its
appetite satiated the foundation's goat
budget is through the roof these days
but it's worth it to keep the thing
contained better to spend money on goats
now and not spend money on cannibalized
Personnel later SCP
24274 consists not of an object located
within a room but the room itself the
room which contains no furniture and a
lenium floor has a pecul effect on the
human psyche once a person steps foot
into the room they lose Consciousness
for 5 minutes during this time they will
speak freely listing off a variety of
negative qualities about themselves once
they wake up they have no memory of
entering the state or anything that they
said during it it's cheaper than therapy
right but it's also much weirder and
less effective so you get what you pay
for in the end a member of d-class
personnel who was observed inside of the
room wax poetic about his personal
failings beginning his monologue with my
soul is a den of spiders and ending it
with oh here once I awaken hesitate not
to feed my flesh and my soul to the
judge Beast somebody give this guy a hug
because the room seems to have no
adverse effects on human test subjects
except for causing everyone who hears
their monologue a bit of discomfort
there are no containment procedures in
effect for it at this time we've had
rooms fire hydrants and horrible meat
robot hybrids and now you can't even
trust the clouds in the sky SCP
24275 is a seemingly innocent Cloud
hovering stationary over the building
when looked at by a human for more than
3 seconds the cloud will eject a ball of
solid lead towards the person at a
supersonic speed that's right folks This
Cloud can and will shoot you it hates
being observed but it also hates when
you try to leave the perimeter it will
attack any person attempting to leave by
firing ing the same lead ball at them so
far 14 Personnel have been killed by
this highly aggressive cloud and some
people still think thunderstorms in hail
are the worst things clouds have to
offer so naive as it is a little Cloud
there is no way to contain it so no
people in the vicinity of the cloud are
permitted to look at it for more than 3
seconds at a time SCP
24276 is a series of 18 small trees
spread throughout the instance of SCP
2427 above ground the trees look normal
though their species has proven
surprisingly difficult to determine from
an external perspective they are simply
ordinary trees however radar analysis
revealed that the roots of these trees
are deeply strange instead of the usual
twisting tree roots the ground below
these trees contains a mass in the shape
of a human body much to the disgust of
the observing researchers these humanoid
masses occasionally twitch and move as
if alive the trees themselves appear to
be growing from the crotch area of each
humanoid figure how's that for
Morningwood I know I get it bad joke
this Arrangement between tree and person
seems to be some kind of punishment as
each tree is marked with a plaque
reading the lrc suffer what they must
and it is beautiful until it can be
certain that the condition of these
human Roots is not contagious these
trees are to be treated as potential
biohazards and isolated in individual
containers the final object in SCP 2427
currently categorized by the foundation
is SCP
24277 SCP
24277 is a pile of ashes and Wood
located just behind a posted sign that
reads the Liar's cradle extensive
testing has been established that the
Liar's cradle was almost certainly used
as a torture device in interrogations
performed by the Brazen heart a person
standing within the boundaries of the
Cradle which encompasses the the
aforementioned circle of wood and Ashes
is unable to lie without suffering the
consequences namely they will be set on
fire the nature of how exactly the
Liar's cradle works is not certain and
more research needs to be done on it
however this much is known for sure it
contains no sentient intelligence it is
not aware of what it is doing it does
not kill its victims rather it keeps
them miraculously alive as it sets them
on fire prolonging their Agony in
allowing their interrogators to get the
truth out of them a series of
experiments revealed that it only ulates
a person who is knowingly lying d-class
Personnel give demonstrably false
information to repeat in the Cradle
without knowledge of its falsehood were
not set on fire however when those same
d-class Personnel knowingly lied in the
boundaries they immediately were set
Ablaze it is almost certain that the
Brazen heart cult used the Cradle as a
method of interrogating presumed Liars
in their m midst further investigation
will likely reveal human remains beneath
the Cradle itself though this is just a
hypothesis currently but come on there
has to be some bone somewhere beneath
something as ominous as the Liar's
cradle though they have only identified
seven anomalies inside SCP 2427 at the
moment there are plenty more lurking in
there waiting to be discovered in the
foyer of SCP
24272 the foundation discovered an
extremely ominous list of items clearly
belonging to members of The Cult of the
Brazen heart this list included some
familiar items such as Pilgrim
Provisions also known as the canned
beans and soup found in SCP
24272 a level three Purity Proctor a
purge engine disguised as a fire hydrant
and the Liar's cradle however it also
contained many things that have not yet
been discovered such as one slaughtering
perseverance 27 py children three
ascended cultivars seven Supreme
angelics Nine Dragons and the Brazen
heart itself Dr Gordon McElroy site
director of area 2427 put out a memo to
all level four and higher Staff assigned
to the area after the discovery of this
list understandably he was most
concerned about the Supreme angelics and
the dragons particularly the latter the
cult as most Cults are is fond of
deliberately obscure language but you
don't want to rule out the possibility
they've got a fire breathing lizard or
two stashed away in the meantime as the
foundation is working to better
understand the contents of SCP
2427 the area has been sealed off to the
public a 500 met perimeter has been
established around its entrance and a
fake private Country Club has been set
up as a front it's only a matter of time
before the rest of the anomalies on the
list are discovered and this thing full
of stuff gets even Fuller of even even
more stuff let's just hope none of it
ever gets out because if there are more
of these addicts out there who knows
what else the Brazen heart is hiding
their little cult may not be as extinct
as we thought somehow most likely
through some nefarious means a fateful
postcard has been sent to one of the
residents of the murky Mysterious aranam
Island living on this particular Island
was already a strange and scary enough
existence given the horrors the
inhabitants of anaram share their home
with but perhaps the only thing just as
horrible as life on that island was
being sent a postcard sure that doesn't
sound all that horrible postcards are
usually used to show a corner of the
world far away and extend well wishes
from friends or relatives on vacations
but ordinarily postcards don't depict a
photo of scp096 with the words wish he
was there scrawled on the other side
from its containment cell at the SCP
Foundation the shy guy instantly sense
that somebody somewhere had seen a
picture of its face breaking down into
an enraged fit of homicidal insecurity
scp096 immediately broke from its
containment chamber and made a
CrossCountry beine heading straight for
arinum at anomalously accelerated speeds
little did the creature or the
foundation know that the shy guy was
being led straight into a trap and the
poor island resident who had received
the chilling postcard while they were
unlucky enough to be the bait while the
SCP Foundation started frantically
trying to track down where it had gone
the shy guy had already made its way to
a wooden cabin belonging to the
unfortunate postcard recipient emerging
from the now emptied home once the owner
was no more scp096 would have returned
to his cell just as quickly as he left
that is if he wasn't the only monstrous
creature on the island allowed and
sudden noise caught the creature's
attention the sound of an old steam
train whistle it rang out once more from
somewhere off in the distance but there
was so much thick fog hanging in the air
around arinum that it was almost
impossible to see anything especially
with how dark it was the second time the
whistle sounded it was closer but there
was another sound too and not the loud
chugging of a steam engine that you
would expect it was an erratic heavy
thuing the noise of lots of something
drumming against the ground causing the
Earth itself to shudder legs they were
the steps of multiple huge legs crawling
across the surface of the island heading
straight towards scp096 a third piercing
whistle rang out even closer still this
this time the orange glow of a light
could be seen dulled by the surrounding
fog but getting brighter and clearer as
it came closer the light was casting
Shadows against the dark fog long spiny
shapes of spidery appendages until
before the shy gui's eyes a creature of
pure nightmares came bursting out of the
fog it was a monstrous sight even to
scp096
its body was the Red Front engine of an
old-fashioned steam train hoisted off
the ground by four pairs of enormous
black spinley spider-like legs that
propelled the Beast forwards at a
terrifying speed able to move without
the limitations of needing to follow a
railroad track the monster was barreling
towards scp096 with a twisted smile on
its grotesque face at the front of the
locomotive was its circular face with
its unnaturally white eyes and a mouth
that sported rows of razor sharp teeth
all covered in blood this hellish
Abomination a being that was part steam
engine and part giant spider was the
terror of arinum himself the carnivorous
Cho Chu Charles seeing Charles racing
towards them on its eight spider legs
would be enough to make anyone freeze up
and stop in their tracks out of sheer
Terror and scp096 was compelled to do
the same except the terrifying train
creature's pale eyes were looking
directly at the shy guy as Charles sized
the anomaly up as its next meal he was
looking at it and that meant scp096
had to kill him the question was how
could it how could the skinny spinley
humanoid hope to even fight something
like cho cho Charles he was much bigger
even more fearsome but as quick as
Charles could move on his spidery legs
he was not fast faster than scp096 in
the blink of an eye the shy guy raced
off shrieking and sobbing in despair
leaving Charles to continue roaming his
island territory in search of other
human inhabitants to terrorize scp096
had retreated to some nearby Woods quick
enough to move out of Charles's path
somewhere it could hide for now but the
shy guy could feel a familiar painful
feeling almost pulling him back towards
Cho Chu Charles right back in to Harm's
Way scp096 possessed an inescapable
compulsion to kill anyone who looked at
its face and that seemed to include
horrifying part train part spider
hybrids it was a fact of the Shy Guy's
very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creatures Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try scp096 knew that if it
did then there was little chance it
would Sur survive coming face to train
face with the terror of arono however
while it was watching Cho Chu Charles
from a safe distance seeing him crawl
across the landscape on his multiple
legs that as scp096 noticed something it
was another light obscured by the fog
but this one was much higher up one
could almost mistake it for the moon if
it wasn't getting closer all the while
accompanied by the sound of woring
rotors while the shy guy had been
evading Choo Chu Charles the SCP found
Foundation had been tirelessly trying to
track down its location and now they'd
found their runaway anomaly here on
aranam island as the chopper carrying
the mobile task force Drew nearer the
tyrannical train turned and took notice
to scp096 the foundation's arrival could
have meant a way home and away from the
spidery steam engine but to Charles the
approaching chopper meant only one thing
a new source of food Captain one of the
MTF troops aboard the chopper called
over his headset what is it do we have
eyes on scp096 the captain replied
before realizing what he'd said well not
eyes on because then it would have
jumped up onto the chopper and killed us
all I mean is there any sign of scp096
on the island negative sir although you
should probably see this the soldier
replied begrudgingly the captain
unbuckled himself from his seat and
snatched the foundation operatives
binoculars using them to look down at
arinum below it didn't take him long to
spot the massive multi-legged
monstrosity that was choo choo Charles
who had fallen still waiting for the
chopper to descend low enough for him to
reach good cravy what on Earth is that
thing the captain exclaimed before
taking another look through the
binoculars is that wait what is an
instance of SCP 2086 doing out here SCP
2086 was an Infamous anomalous species
the foundation had encountered before
much like Charles they were anthropod
likee creatures with multiple long legs
that protruded from a body resembling a
man-made mode of transport however SCP
286s usually took on the appearance of
buses while in vehicle form sir I I
don't think that's an SCP 2086 the
lookout replied to me it looks more like
an instance of SCP 3023 impossible all
the way out here the captain retorted
we're nowhere near the region where the
anomaly occurs that could have scurried
its way from Germany and taken Nest here
sir the trooper responded yet another
anomaly that cho cho Charles bore a
striking resemblance to SCP 323 was a
rare phenomenon that was known to occur
at random but was limited to a specific
area of central Germany the effect of
this phenomenon caused ordinary everyday
inanimate objects of any shape or size
to suddenly turn into aggressive spiders
sporting eight legs That Grew From
whatever was affected by SCP 3023
perhaps Chuchu Charles was indeed an
instance of SCP 3023 or some distant
evolutionary offshoot of SCP 2086 it was
hard to say for sure the only thing for
sure was that Charles was a man-eating
Beast more so than an Insidious villain
and being so highly territorial he
considered the entire island of arinum
to be his natural habitat and his
hunting ground anything that arrived in
his vicinity was prey to the terrifying
train and his ravenous craving for human
flesh meant he was ready to attack the
descending SCP Foundation Chopper all
right let's go go go oh the MTF Captain
called to his troops signaling them to
start repelling out of the helicopter
and down to the island keep your
scramble goggles on Max we still need to
recapture 096 but first priority is
taking down this big ugly beast wearing
goggles specifically designed to distort
the shy guy from their view the team
began ABS selling out of the aircraft
but Cho Chu Charles was already waiting
for them rearing back on its for back
legs the nightmares train spider swiped
at the descending MTF operatives would
first seem like a an instinctive
uncoordinated assault quickly became
precise and Relentless strikes as
Charles sliced through some of the
cables the MTF troops were using to
repel down their Lifeline cut the
Unlucky Foundation operatives plummeted
from midair right down towards where the
terror of Aaron niram was waiting for
them to fall a few of the mtfs made it
to the ground alive and immediately
began retaliating against chuch Chu
Charles the gunfire from their weapons
flickered all around the carnivorous
creature but their bullets could barely
chipped the red paintwork on his steam
train body dashing towards his helpless
human prey on his many legs Charles
began to Feast then suddenly something
started pulling at one of his huge
spider legs pulling Charles back moments
before he had a chance to claim his
latest victim the captain of the
foundation's MTF it was scp096 having
zipped out of hiding and shrieking
wildly as it used all of its strength to
wrench one of choo Cho Charles's
multiple limbs angered that it couldn't
reach the the MTF Captain the part
spider part train hybrid stomped the leg
that was being pulled in a successful
attempt to free itself from the shy gu's
grip but in the same instant scp096 used
its anomalous speed to reappear in front
of the already angered locomotive
monster with his railroad rage about to
reach its Breaking Point Charles entered
into a Relentless Rampage making quick
work of the leftover MTF troops before
setting his sight squarely on scp096 but
do that was his biggest mistake now Cho
Chu Charles had seen the shy guy twice
and to the insecure anomaly that meant
Charles had to go traveling faster than
even the multi-legged monstrosity could
perceive scp096 began racing towards
Chuchu Charles's many legs the shy guy
had realized that it didn't stand a
chance of dealing with the terror of
arinum the same way it handled all the
others that had seen its face so instead
it had settled on a new approach
approach specifically tailored to taking
down the spider legged steam engine one
by one SC scp096 started knocking
Charles's many legs out from underneath
him effectively tripping him up over and
over again the shy guy moved so quick
that the cumbersome Charles could barely
react in time having one leg after the
other knocked out from beneath him
causing him to Tumble to the ground
normally Choo Cho Charles was smart
enough to retreat if he encountered
something that could fight back if he
was injured badly enough the spider-like
creature would Scuttle out of Harm's Way
in order to heal his wounds but the rage
at being constantly tripped up by scp096
was distracting Charles from the shy
guys's true Ploy with every leg it
knocked out from underneath the spidery
steam train scp096 had been gradually
directing Charles towards a nearby Gorge
with a terrifying burst of anomalous
speed the shy guy caused Cho Chu Charles
to topple over sideways rolling over
himself until he landed up upside down
in the bottom of the Rocky Gorge the
multi-legged locomotive Monster's
spindly legs flailed desperately as he
tried to reposition himself but with no
luck scp096 had managed what first
seemed to be impossible and beaten the
terror of Aon niram Cho Chu Charles or
for now at least one fine morning your
distant Aunt Carol came to your family
home in an almost frantic state of
excitement Carol had always been a bit
exent
totally harmless of course but what you
describe as being on the more zealous
side of religious predictably she wanted
to ask you and your family to come to
church with her seeing as you don't see
Aunt Carol often you and your family
decide that there's no harm in indulging
her you're not an atheist family by any
means in fact you were all raised
Catholic but it felt like it' been
forever since you last went to church
Aunt Carol wanted to show you and your
family the special celebrations that
went on at her church you remember
remember her practically grabbing you by
the wrist and dragging you to the
building her eyes filled with a crazed
enthusiasm that's when you saw something
incredibly strange there were Shadows
moving behind the elaborate stained
glass windows thousands of tiny Shadows
darting around and this low humming
noise you faintly recognized what was
that noise it was the Cry of cicas but
this was only early spring what were
cicas doing awake at this time time of
year you didn't get much time to ponder
this question in the next few seconds
you and the entire church were
surrounded by heavyduty tactical
Vehicles what appeared to be a large and
heavily armed SWAT team poured out of
the vehicles unbeknownst to you these
were a mobile task force sent in by the
SCP Foundation specifically MTF y99 also
known as the alter boys a specially
trained group of foundation agents used
for anomalies of a religious nature you
your aunt and the rest rest of your
family are rounded up to be debriefed
and given amnestics one of the last
memories they took from you was the
sight of foundation agents dragging
bloody bodies out of the church as the
doors opened thousands of cicas streamed
out and disappeared into the skies but
these weren't like any kind of cicada
you'd ever seen they were beautiful the
rainbow colored Wings reminded you of
ornate stained glass who could have
guessed that these pretty little bugs
are tied to an entity very likely to
bring about an XK Class end of the world
scenario someday in the future the bugs
the bodies in the church and even your
aunt's incredibly strange Behavior All
Fall underneath the umbrella of a ker
class anomaly known as SCP
3004 but to truly understand this
anomaly that was once thought to be
destroyed and the implications of it
still living today we need to go back
600 years to Ireland in the 15th century
this era was believed to be the origin
of a Gaelic religious movement known as
Ki or the singers in English a splinter
sect of druidism but this was no fringe
cult the singers were a mainstream
religion in the British Isles for
several hundred years its members
included people of all social classes
from lowly peasants to powerful and
respected figures they mingled heavily
with Christians mostly Irish Catholics
and at some point in history came close
to overtaking Christianity as the
dominant religion in Ireland so who were
these people if they're supposedly such
a large part of recent history in the
area like most Druids their relationship
with nature was a key part of their
belief system in particular they prized
an extinct species of cicada known as
Ceta luculent or the stained glass
cicada in English the life cycle of
birth and resurrection that the cicas
underwent fascinated the singers and
they performed a number of holy rituals
around it one recorded ritual was the
celebration of children and entering
adulthood that was marked by them first
losing their baby teeth but the rituals
of the singers accidentally opened some
kind of door to a being from a different
plane of reality dubbed SCP 34-1 by the
foundation this being is an immensely
powerful thought form that the
foundation believes to be a ptis phase
or faith eater it appears to have been
attracted to our universe by the rituals
of the singers and so took a form
relevant to their beliefs namely a huge
AA in order to feed on their faith if
things had stopped there then this would
be an almost innocent symbiotic
relationship but the interactions
between SCP 34-1 and RoR led to
dangerous consequences due to its
powerful reality warping abilities for
example during some rituals huge numbers
of stained glass cicas would burst from
the mouths of those participating often
causing them to choke to death other
times 34-1 would manifest physically in
the sky above its new worshippers
causing painful boils on whoever
witnessed it and occasionally symptoms
akin to radiation sickness it appeared
that 34-1 was growing more powerful over
time and its rise to power was
intrinsically linked to the rituals of
the singers and the existence of the
stained glass cicas two groups that
predated the foundation the vatican's
congregation for otherworldly acts and
the English government's Royal Society
for the imprisonment of abnormality
essentially performed an allout
religious genocide on the singers no
meaningful trace of the religion was
left when they were done aside from
their own records while they were at it
they also exterminated all the stained
glass cicas leading to a complete stop
of all SCP 3004 activity it seemed like
despite the great human and ecological
cost the anomaly had been neutralized a
few centuries later though a series of
strange cic related anomalous events
started to occur across the United
States a strange man seemingly made
almost entirely from cicada Kiton would
appear at christenings weddings and
funerals each time his presence would
cause the people in attendance to do and
experience horrific things and lead to
legacies of hardship and death that
would linger for decades this became
known as SCP 2852 or cousin Johnny and
it should have been the first clue that
the nightmare of SCP 3004 was
resurfacing but since 3004 was already
archived as neutralized nobody made the
connection sometime later SCP 2852
incident ceased and around that exact
time SCP 3004 instances started a new it
manifested in the form of strange
anomalous activities taking place at
Christian church services specifically
those from Roman Catholic Eastern
Catholic Anglican and Episcopalian
communities the only Clues to Outsiders
would be an increase in reported Church
attendance
and an increase in deaths from natural
causes within the community these two
stats were how the foundation first
noticed something was a Miss just as it
had done with the singers centuries
before SCP 34-1 had latched onto the
beliefs and rituals of Christians and
was using this new connection to harvest
more faith for sustenance the results
were twofold first religious fever and
excitement to attend church services saw
a huge increase secondly the actual
content of these Services took a hard
turn for the horrific much like cousin
Johnny infiltrations this really isn't
for the faint of heart by any definition
for example young people with Christlike
Stigmata wounds being bitten to death by
priests children removing the teeth of
priests before they all start vomiting
huge numbers of stained glass cicas
there were extremely unpleasant rituals
involving castration and even a pregnant
woman giving birth to even more swarms
of stained glass cicas we could go on
but you probably get the idea rituals
inspired by SCP 34-1 are horrific and
all seem to involve the same extinct
breed of stained glass cicas worshiped
by the singers before their Annihilation
but how can these insects which have
been dubbed SCP
34-2 be here in the present if the
foundation forerunners made them extinct
so many centuries ago the answer is
simple but strange well they have all
the Hallmarks of being alive the stained
glass cicas present during modern
iterations of SCP 3004 events aren't
actually real genetic tests have shown
that they're actually made from a mix of
wood and real stained glass these
insects Fly Away From The Scene after
the rituals are completed traveling
around 600 M from the site before
disappearing completely the foundation
was growing concerned about the nature
of SCP 3004 especially given that
instances were becoming more frequent
and harder to contain found Foundation
scientists determined that the creature
known as 34-1 likely existed within a
layer of reality just above our own and
if it ever managed to breach our reality
the World level of violence and Chaos it
could cause would likely lead to an XK
Class end of the world scenario drastic
actions would once again be needed to
prevent this so they devised an
emergency containment procedure that
would only be used as a last resort the
procedure known as protocol damanti
odesus would use mixture of mass
amnestic treatment and Thal objects to
completely erase Christianity from not
only the modern world but all of history
in hopes of cutting off SCP 34-1 food
supply to kill the entity or at least
prevent it from entering our world the
plan would Center on placing a powerful
Roman Catholic reality warper who
volunteered for the job of course into
an anomalous group of machines known as
the Lions by submitting the reality
warper to a lifetime of suffering and a
essentially erasing him from existence
so too will it erase the world's full
knowledge of Christianity and hopefully
save the world this man will become the
last martyr dying for all of humanity he
will become the last saint St Jude the
damed bullwark against Darkness you
might ask are you sure that's necessary
there's so much we don't know about
34-1 do we know for a fact that it's
dangerous enter agent Timothy lutterman
a member of mobile task force sign 25
also known as Ghostbusters lutterman was
part of a foundation project known as
sight SE Lux using an astral projection
technology that would free his
Consciousness from his body and allow it
to travel freely between metaphysical
planes in plain English they could use
Letterman's floating mind as a kind of
spy and insert it into
34-1 Dimension they achieved this by
capturing one of 34-1 false stained
glass cicas and releasing it again
allowing Letterman's mind to follow it
home to its Master however what we
thought would be a simple Intel
gathering mission turned into a complete
nightmare Letterman found that 34-1
Dimension was entirely void aside from
the entity itself and the millions of
buzzing stained glass cicas The Entity
was so huge and so complex that it
physically hurt to look at Letterman
observed that its form kept shifting
from a giant cicada to an old man to a
cicada nailed to a wooden cross to an
infinite mess of wood and stained glass
but even more terrifying than its
physical appearance were the contents of
its mind 34-1 forced itself into agent
Letterman's brain and in that moment he
finally understood it the entity which
had no concept of metaphors allegory or
the Divide between fact and fiction
truly believe that it was the abrahamic
god depicted in the Bible and that all
Christians are lovingly worshiping it in
its rituals it was imposing some of the
bloodiest parts of the Bible onto its
flock believing that's what they wanted
all the while it fed on their faith
growing bigger and more powerful
Letterman found that just being there
with the creature was hurting his soul
if it wasn't a god yet he believed it
had the power to become one in time and
he advised the foundation shouldn't send
anyone else to its Dimension it was too
great a risk to all life on Earth
perhaps to prevent the horrible fate of
all of us being destroyed by
34-1 a race ing Christianity would be a
worthy sacrifice that is if it actually
works after all they thought destroying
the singers would neutralize 304 once
and for all and yet here it is again for
all we know we may just be prolonging
the inevitable disturbing things had
been happening on the fifth floor of the
Rose Heights apartment building in
Albany New York residents had reported
strange noises over the last few days
Screaming in the Night pained muttering
soft weeping scratching and scuttling in
the walls and worst of all would seemed
like an infestation of bugs unlike
anything the unfortunate occupants of
Rose Heights had ever seen before they
weren't abnormal in size or shape they
looked an awful lot like the common
earwig around 2 and 1/2 cm long with
large curved pinches on the back but the
color wasn't right unlike the usual dark
brown these earwigs were silverly almost
translucent gray when people spotted
them crawling across their walls or
hiding in the carpet they seemed to
Shimmer in the light eventually the
building's landl Donna Tomkins was
called in to do something about the
infestation she spoke to each of the
residents about their experience they
reported the strange noises the
mysterious bugs and even a funny smell
they'd sometimes catch in the hall a
smell like someone had thrown up and
every single person that Donis spoke to
couldn't help but remark that the smell
was particularly strong outside the
apartment of a certain resident Bill
parm stranger still was the fact that
bill hadn't been seen in days Donna
knocked on his door but received no
answer she called him on his cell phone
and could hear the phone ringing inside
the apartment but it just went to
voicemail when she checked the security
footage of the lobby she saw that bill
hadn't left the building in the last few
days either Donna called the police
worried that bill might be sick or even
dead inside his apartment it was strange
given that he was only in his 30s and
didn't seem to have any health
conditions but stranger things had
happened much stranger things were about
to happen too two police officers
arrived not long after they called
through the door one more time and when
they got no response Donna gave them the
key to head inside the apartment was a
rack all the furniture was was covered
in dust filthy dishes were piled high in
the sink and on the draining board the
smell of rot was thick in the air there
were empty boxes of painkillers all the
pills popped from their silvery foil
laying on the ground but worst of all
were the bugs the apartment was crawling
with them and they were on every surface
those silvery gray earwigs neither of
the officers like bugs and it seemed
like the deeper they got into the
apartment the more bugs there were some
even seemed to be crawling towards them
pointing their Pines at them as though
they were defending their territory this
looked to be a textbook case of what
happens when a resident heels over and
dies but there was just one problem
where was the body Bill parum had
seemingly dropped off the face of the
Earth and now a colony of mysterious
bugs had started squatting in his
apartment in his absence then came that
smell again that truly awful smell smell
like bile and blood it was even stronger
now and it seemed like it was coming
from a nearby closet the two officers
acting on pure Instinct Drew their
weapons and approached the closet with
caution even if they weren't consciously
aware of it they knew they were going to
find something awful inside something
evil something dangerous when they threw
open the closet door they couldn't help
but scream they'd found the nest it was
a huge Hive like the biggest beehive
you've ever seen melded into the lower
corner of the closet the unnatural ear
wigs were crawling into out of and
around it thousands of them tens of
thousands of them and the second they
registered the presence of the two
officers Intruders into their nest they
began to swarm in sheer Panic both
raised their guns and open fire into the
closet but it didn't do them any good
their bullets just pierced and
splintered the The Hive causing even
more enraged insects to spill out and
begin crawling over the two cops they
fled from the apartment screaming in
pain from the nashing pincers of the
insects crawling all over their skin
they never did find the corpse of Bill
param but that's because Bill parum
wasn't dead at least not until mere
moments ago when the bullets from the
cops' gun had torn through his bones and
perforated his organs he died not long
after and if he could still speak close
to the end he would have thank them both
for the mercy because the monstrosity
that they just encountered in the closet
wasn't just a nest of mysterious insects
in Bill parm's apartment it was Bill
himself this is the fade worse than
death in store for anyone supremely
unlucky enough to fall victim to SCP 439
better known by the nickname for their
unique nests the boneh hiive and while
these nasty little critters may be small
they're filled with enough pure
nightmare fuel to send you running into
682s containment chamber for a little
Comfort let's go through this whole
nightmarish process and tell you exactly
what happened to poor Bill parum first
discovered by the SCP Foundation in
mainland China SCP 439 specimens largely
get by on the fact that they're not much
to look at unless you're an entomologist
when you see a strange insect you
probably just accept the fact that it's
a perfectly normal breed you've just
never encountered before nobody is
hammering down the doors of their local
news station to alert the Press about
the gray earwig they saw crawling out of
a crack in their bathroom wall but if
Bill parm had done just that it would
have saved his life the foundation would
have immediately flagged the incident as
an SCP 439 infestation and dispatched
the mobile task force to deal with it
instead when Bill saw the earwig for the
first time he was getting ready for work
and didn't have the time to stop and
deal with it he made a mental note to
buy some bug killer on the way home but
quickly forgot the insect didn't forget
him though in fact it thought he would
be a perfect candidate for the SCP 439
process the foundation has tested
extensively with the one SCP 439 sample
they'd been able to successfully catch
and contain in all tests they found that
439 specimens rejected hosts from any
species other than humans they're an
extraordinarily specific parasite it's
also only one particular type of SCP 439
specimen that you actually need to worry
about the Queens despite their
superficial similarities SCP 439 behav
nothing like non-anomalous earwigs
normal earwigs are not social creatures
they're solitary scavengers and they
don't keep nests as permanent habitats
the same can definitely not be said for
SCP 439 they have complex social
structures much like that of bees ants
and termites with Queens Scouts workers
and warriors if you happen to encounter
a worker or a warrior you may get a
painful pinch from their Pinchers if you
get too close but if you end up on the
wrong side of one of the Queens then you
have a much much worse fate in store for
you and it just so happened that the SCP
439 specimen that appeared in Bill
parm's bathroom that morning was
visiting royalty this 439 Queen had
selected her Target and now it was time
to move to the next part of the process
initial infiltration
when Bill returned home from work he was
delighted to find that the gray earwig
was nowhere to be seen but that didn't
mean it was gone it was still there
lurking it just didn't want to be seen
after all the real fun would happen
after bill went to bed once SCP 439
detects that its potential host has
fallen into a deep sleep it will crawl
onto the person's body and into their
mouth which is exactly what it did to
Bill it feels like little more than a
tickle in in your throat and you will
have no idea that the tiny creature
crawling down your windpipe and into the
soft warm tissue of your lungs spells
your doom very few people wake up during
this process but even if they did
There's virtually nothing they could do
when Bill woke up he was suffering from
mild chest pains and shortness of breath
a symptom not uncommon in a number of
respiratory ailments he had no idea that
the SCP 439 Queen was already inside him
he got up and went about day trying to
ignore the pain as it gradually grew
worse and worse feeling almost like
something was moving inside his chest he
spent the whole day having to stop to
let out a deep hacking cough but
coughing didn't expel or change anything
he looked and felt so terrible that his
boss let him go home early hoping that
bill would be able to sleep off whatever
illness he thought he had picked up but
over the next couple of days his
condition only worsened the pain grew so
excruciating he could barely move and he
was popping painkillers like Tic Tacs to
no effect he started running a
dangerously high fever his body trying
in vain to fight back against its lethal
Intruder he felt worse than he ever had
in his life but little did poor Bill
know the most terrible parts of the
process were yet to come through
anomalous means an SCP 439 infection is
able to induce fibrodisplasia oans
progressiva or fop and its victims which
is typically a genetic disease that
presents itself before the victim turns
10 years old the condition is Infamous
for its primary symptom turning muscle
and other soft tissue into bone slowly
but surely paralyzing the victim and
putting them into a state of unspeakable
pain this bone transformation process is
known as oifc and Bill was about to
experience it firstand his pain
increased as his Mobility decreased with
more of his flesh becoming solid lumps
of the bone underneath the skin soon
enough all he knew was pain it become so
agonizing that he was delirious with it
he was drunk on pain even perceiving
sunlight felt like being stabbed in the
eyes that's why like all the other
victims of SCP 439 he decided to conceal
himself in a warm dark place where no
light could get to him in Bill's case of
course that place was his closet he was
hurting so bad that all he could do was
curl up into the fetal position and weep
as his muscles turned to bone and his
body began to Compact and Shrink he
didn't even look like a human anymore he
was more like a ball covered in a bone
shell and filled with warm organs that's
when the queen started laying eggs among
his organs it wasn't long before there
was a new brood of around 30,000
specimens living inside Bill's body he
was still very much alive but there
wasn't anything he could do about his
situation ation his muscles had long
since turned to bone and they had eaten
large portions of his brain leaving
mainly the parts needed to keep his
organs just barely functioning after all
the colony still needs central heating
SCP 439 colonies have developed a
perfect parasitic relationship with the
human body they even used the stomach
inside the hive to pre- digest food into
a liquid slurry that's easier for them
to consume the only loser in this
situation is someone like Bill who is
forced to become the new home for the
world's most nightmarish freeloaders
eventually when the colony becomes too
big a queen departs to start a new one
and the process repeats itself once more
it's enough to make you want to sleep
with your mouth closed for the rest of
your life oh and we haven't even told
you the worst part yet Foundation
scientists have conducted tests on some
victims of SCP 439 and found that while
the creatures do consume large parts of
the brain the parts they leave are
capable of Consciousness that's right
their victims remain aware of what's
happening to them the whole time even
when they hardly seem human at all
anymore what actually finally kills the
victims of SCP 439 isn't the bodily
trauma it's the starvation that sets in
when the colony inevitably moves on did
we just hear you cough you might want to
go get that checked out when it comes to
bugs the SCP Foundation certainly has
its hands full you you might remember
SCP 726 a species of bowly aptly named
the reconstructive maggots who recreated
the bodies of other organisms through
horrible reproduction methods there's
also SCP 2031 a colony of anomalous ants
that would eat their victims insides and
burrow themselves in the bodies
puppeting them around and masquerading
as the creature they just ate even if it
was a person today on SCP explained
we're going to be talking about a new
species of anomalous insect CP 378
nicknamed The brainworm Well it's an
anomaly only new to us for the
foundation SCP 378 Discovery and
containment dates back to the days of
the American Secure containment
initiative the American Secure
containment initiative could be
considered a predecessor to the SCP
Foundation active for the majority of
the first half of the 20th century well
most of the stories go that the asci
alongside several other paranormal
investig ation organizations eventually
came together and formed the SCP
Foundation in the early 50s the reality
is a lot murkier as we all know it's
very hard to completely kill off an
organization in the anomalous world the
secrecy and decentralization practically
ensures that there's always going to be
some stragglers left and in the asci's
case that certainly seems to be the case
SCP 378 file indicates that by
1963 the asci was still around in
kicking though it was definitely living
on borrowed time due to the rising
prominence of the SCP Foundation the two
organizations the growing foundation and
the dying asci attempted to keep tabs on
one another throughout the decade but
the foundation's Espionage programs
proved to be more intensive and thorough
for whatever reason the foundation was
always getting the best Intel whether it
was beating the asci to the punch on
newly discovered anomalies gaining
access to otherwise classified
information only available in asci
documents of the highest security
clearances or finding ways to benefit
from the organization's detriments
through diplomatic meetings that always
seemed to work in the foundation's favor
it was clear that the SCP Foundation was
the new hotness and the asci would have
a lot of catching up to do if it wanted
to remain relevant in this new post
World War II World unfortunately we all
know what happened the majority of the
asci was absorbed into the foundation
shortly after its formation and the
pieces that remained would Fade Into
Obscurity in the coming years but why
was the foundation's Intel so good more
funding better trained agents luck the
answer if you're familiar with the
foundation's ways shouldn't come as a
surprise of course there was always
going to be more going on behind the
scenes and that's where SCP 378 comes in
SCP 378 is an arthropod resembling an
Amazonian giant centipede specifically
one in the larvel stage SCP 378 measures
about 3 m long with a thickness of 233
kg and it possesses otherwise ordinary
biological features while about as
normal as an anomaly contained by the
SCP Foundation can get on the dietary
side it eats like a normal centipede
consuming primarily other insects and
lyan on the reproductive side things are
a bit different SCP 378 reproduces a sex
meaning that it's capable of generating
Offspring entirely through its own
biological functions which it excretes
from its backside a newly birthed
instance designated SCP
378a resembles a fully grown adult
Amazonian giant centipede right from
birth but dissection of these baby peeds
suggests that this resemblance is
superficial as SCP 378 A's organ systems
Beyond A Primitive neural network are
entirely nonexistent these babies are
essentially shell organisms intended to
be used by SCP 378 the host centipede as
remote drones and that's how SCP 378
proves to be useful to the foundation at
large you see 378a are endoparasites
meaning that they're organisms that live
inside other organisms like a tapeworm
but so so much worse SCP 378a are used
by SCP 378 to ffect Advanced primates
such as ourselves but also a whole host
of offshoots of humanity such as the
homo ignotus also known as SCP 655 and
the gigantopithecus sapiens the common
Sasquatch which you might recognized as
SCP 1000 SCP 378a enters a host through
an open orifice and after infection The
Entity will integrate itself with the
host's nervous system through means that
are poorly understood by the foundation
this includes brain death of the host
and extending SCP 378 remote control
through its Offspring and into the host
itself vital functions and sensory input
remain unaffected meaning that the host
still retains some semblance of Life
function just you know without a brain
or anything they're not there they're
just puppets but you'll never be able to
tell when you think of someone being
puppeted by an anomalous parasite you'd
probably expect them to act a little
weird maybe they don't don't speak right
or maybe they start slithering on the
floor eating only small lizards but
that's not the case with victims of SCP
378 no once its Offspring Have infected
a suitable host SCP 378 will actually do
a pretty decent job of integrating its
victims back into their respective
social sphere this means maintaining all
of their previous relationships as best
as possible such as keeping their jobs
and otherwise fitting in and not
standing above the crowd you'd prob
assume they prefer to keep a low profile
mainly infecting hosts in small towns
and sleepy suburbs but you'd be wrong
there too SCP 378 loves the big city
places with high population density and
a robust entertainment scene we'll
explain later but SCP 378 differs from
ordinary insects in that its based
Instinct isn't to just infect and
reproduce it's to have fun and the way
it entertains itself is by living the
lives of people who otherwise live busy
engaging lives filled with plenty of
Social interactivity and places to go
the foundation has yet to discover the
upper limit of SCP 378 as the centipede
has managed to infect quite a number of
hosts with its Offspring which it all
seems to maintain simultaneously without
issue upon interrogation of a host SCP
378 confesses to the existence of 26
human hosts two instances of guatemal
and black Hower monkeys and three
instances of SCP 1000 considering the
complex social hierarchies of monkeys
it's unsurprising that SCP 378 infected
a few of them just to try them out on
top of infecting a few Sasquatches in
the form of SCP 1000 which SCP 378
conveniently is immune to the inherent
anomalous effects of but there is no
question as to which species SCP 378
prefers in fact those other things that
infected according to the host were only
acquired during periods of heavy
intoxication see the centipede enjoys
getting a little tipsy too you can't
have that in the Amazon rainforest as
humanity is the dominant species on
Earth we're the ones with the shiniest
toys for SCP 378 to play with the most
exciting lives filled with more
pointless interaction and labor than a
bug would know what to do with and
that's what makes SCP 378 so intriguing
for the foundation it's an intelligent
parasite whose only motivation is to
keep Society Running as normal so it can
slip behind a few pairs of human eyes
and see what it's like in the world it
would never get to otherwise live in
some of you are already thinking it but
SCP 378 is the perfect anomaly for the
foundation to use against its foes and
adversaries and as we covered earlier in
the 1960s the foundation had a lot to
prove mainly against the American Secure
containment initiative the foundation
knew to classify SCP 378 as a Thal class
object it was promptly contained in an
underground terrarium filled with plenty
of Juicy lyen and ants for SCP 378 to
feed on of course there was also a
decontamination chamber constructed
adjacent to the regular containment
chamber any Personnel who would go in
would obviously be at risk to an
infection from SCP 378 and were sure
that living the crazy exciting life of a
foundation agent would have satisfied
the sociable bug but the SCP Foundation
wasn't taking any risks as a result
anyone entering the chamber would have
to wear full body protection and if they
were found to be infected during the
decontamination process they would be
terminated after discovery of SCP 378
the foundation immediately saw the
potential in utilizing the anomaly for
Espionage purposes after all it would be
a perfect spy Network capable of fitting
in and maintaining ordinary roles while
also communicating with SCP 378 who
would feed information to the foundation
through another host the impeccable
Precision of SCP 378 maintenance of its
hosts social personas would make the
entity almost impenetrable to sniff out
in the field even for trained agents who
deal with the anomalous SCP 378 initial
psychological evaluation was performed
by the well-known Foundation
psychologist Dr Simon glass Dr glass
found that SCP 378 was obviously unique
among arthropods and possessed either
human level of sapience or at the very
least the ability to emulate it hosts
intellectual faculties regardless the
anomaly was intelligent but a point of
interest for Dr glass was as CP 378
relationship with its hosts it
maintained a constant consistent sense
of identity across multiple hosts but
interviews with SCP 378 revealed that it
was fully aware that it was not those
hosts in actuality SCP 378 was
essentially roleplaying various human
identities it wasn't just easy for the
foundation to figure out that the the
centipede enjoyed masquerading as its
hosts it pretty much spelled it out with
giant letters SCP 378 hosts rarely
interact with or send information
directly back to SCP 378 or fellow hosts
because SCP 378 is in full control at
all times this is literally just a game
for SC SCP 378 a source of entertainment
and if one of those hosts came under
duress or was at risk of being found out
by those in its life 378 could abandon
the host Persona which it had no issues
in doing Dr glass found that the host
Behavior was largely unique to each
instance and extroverted personalities
were a favorite for SCP 378 hosts rarely
isolate themselves except as sleep or
use the bathroom and SCP 378 appeared to
take equal enthusiasm in both stressful
and pleasant situations after all this
was all a big role playing session for
it SCP 378 appreciated some exci
excitement in the lives of its subjects
in a way this was like an infinite
source of entertainment you could live
as many lives as you wanted at once have
almost no attachment to any consequences
because you're a bug who has no stake in
the real world and you get to experience
things no other member of your species
ever has or ever will SCP 378 really is
living the dream even to another human
this sounds pretty fun we only get One
Life to Live SCP 378 gets to live as
many as it wants but Dr glass found
another interesting fact about SCP 378
it was attached to a certain identity
Lisa Martin a 33-year-old
Mexican-American female employee at
digiana tono's pies a pizza chain
located in Staten Island New York Dr
glass was a bit unsure as to why SCP 378
enjoyed Miss Martin so much but it was
clear from the way it talked about her
that this was its favorite Persona and
Dr Dr glass could see why the more he
studied Martin's routine it was the
perfect mixture of business idleness
routine labor and general engagement for
SCP 378 to experience Lisa Martin's
routine was static on every day except
Saturday from 8:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m.
Lisa Martin would show up to work at
digian tono's pies after she finished
work from 6:00 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. Martin
would engage in maintenance of one of 17
rooftop gardens across New York City of
these Gardens glass discovered that 13
are maintained by volunteer
organizations 12 of which Martin was not
a part of on Saturdays from 8:00 a.m. to
11:00 p.m. Martin alternated between
socializing with a collection of friends
and co-workers and playing piano for
various high-end bars on all days from
11:00 p.m. to 12:00 a.m. Martin would
shower and then prepare for bed she
would sleep from 12:00 a.m. to 7:00 a.m.
and in the morning she'd get back up and
do it all over again when you see a
person schedule laid out like this
everything seems a bit more routine and
less exciting huh it's not an exciting
life laid out on paper but SCP 378 loved
it for whatever reasons attempts to
interrupt Lisa Martin's routine were
unilaterally met with unusual levels of
hostility from the bug and its hosts and
in the event of Lisa Martin's death SCP
378 would happily direct another host to
assume her identity yeah we're we're not
sure either regardless 378 had a hobby
many hobbies but Lisa Martin was special
Dr glass's evaluation proved to be
popular with the upper ranks of the
foundation who due to SCP 378
intelligence and awareness of human
sentients could prove to be useful to
the overall mission of the foundation as
we said before in
1963 the foundation had to contend with
a number of powerful adjacent
organizations the global occult
Coalition with their destructive
Tendencies and the backing of the world
governments Gru division P the Soviet
Union's anomalous research military unit
the remnants of the American Secure
containment initiative who while not as
prominent or as powerful as they used to
be still remained an organization
capable of deterring the foundation as a
result the foundation looked into
applying SCP 378 through practical means
Dr glass's work importance could not be
understated but the prevailing theory
was that SCP 378 did not understand the
significance of social dynamics in
regards to hierarchy and Social Capital
this could be observed in its strange
defense of Lisa Martin several of SCP
378 hosts help positions of power two of
which David locked and Alfonso Leos were
even employed by anomalous organizations
and beyond the reach of the foundation's
then capacity to contain even holding
these powerful positions SCP 378
displayed a willingness to sacrifice the
hosts to defend replace or otherwise
maintain Lisa Martin it's
favorite host it was here when the
foundation saw an opportunity if they
could use SCP 378 favoritism of Martin
to get it to do what they wanted their
dream spy Network had a chance of
manifesting into reality David Lockheed
one of SCP 378 hosts was a low-level
employee of the asci but if the
foundation was able to persuade SCP 378
using Martin's safety as collateral loed
could rise through the ranks of the
organization into a position where the
foundation needed a puppet second they
realized that Martin herself could prove
to be a useful asset the foundation was
always looking for new ways to conduct
reconnaissance and pizza parlors were an
ideal meeting spot and Espionage Center
if they could be kept from the public
eye Martin's place of employment would
soon be converted from your average
Staten Island pizza parlor to one of the
foundation's very own spicy crust pizza
chains see what they did there spicy
Crust Pizza
SCP they are are so clever regardless
the use of SCP 378 anomalous abilities
to defend foundation operatives in the
United States seemed like a useful
Prospect and the idea was put to a vote
by the overseer Council it passed with
only minor detrition under the name of
the Kraken protocol as a result SCP 378
containment procedures were updated and
containment of the anomaly would be
focused on three primary components its
first host SCP 378 1 was held in the
area 19 Barracks of the SCP Foundation
dash1 was employed as a maintenance
technician with a low security clearance
and in the case of death a brain dead or
comos Reserve Personnel would be elected
to replace it SCP 3781 served as the
foundation's primary means of
communication with SCP 378 after all
they needed a channel to speak directly
to the bug in charge and -1 was their
way of doing so SCP 378 D2 was David
Lockheed an average employee of the
American Secure containment initiative
working in their clerical sector locked
was tasked with sabotaging asci
operations for the foundation as well as
collecting information in the
foundation's interests SCP 378 D2 was a
little more difficult to replace than
the average SCP 378 host and was
required to follow a strict health and
exercise regimen if something were to
happen to locked there's no telling if
the foundation would be able to replace
him and the chances of that happening
were low locked was the perfect spy with
an established rapport with the asci
going back at least a decade and access
to information the foundation would use
to outsmart the initiative at every turn
it shouldn't come as a surprise to you
that the asci's days were numbered and
eventually they closed their doors
entirely SCP 3783 was Lisa Martin who
worked at spicy Crust Pizza in Staten
Island Martin's purpose was to maintain
a network for foundation operatives in
New York and host a place where they
could congregate and meet without issue
on top of that Martin was still as CP
378 favorite Persona and the entire
operation hinged on SCP 378 having
Martin available to it as a result Lisa
Martin would have to be replaced as soon
as possible if anything were to happen
to her and with that the Kraken protocol
was in place each instant formed a part
of the foundation's information
gathering campaign and was out fitted
with a tracking device and an audio
recorder every week embedded agents
station near each host were to evaluate
the health and integrity of them and the
equipment they had inside them if this
initial rollout was a success the
foundation would continue to use S SCP
378a in further infiltration of its
enemies but the foundation would have to
see how things played out first less
than 2 years later locked had retrieved
significant information for the
foundation and the Kraken protocol
proved to be a success a new site site
56 located near prominent anomalous
locations was about to be constructed SC
SCP 378 seemed excited at the prospects
of a change in scenery and more hosts to
infiltrate but there was also something
the foundation could never have expected
in an attempt to gain a new host for SCP
378 to control the foundation came
across something disturbing their target
was an agent of the FBI's unusual
incident unit after drugging him and
bringing him back to the foundation in
order to receive an SCP 378a instance
inside him SCP 378 informed the
foundation that it couldn't establish a
connection with the agent the Personnel
were confused the agent was still alive
and 378 never had any difficulty in
connecting with hosts before they did a
number of tests on the agent and tried
to figure out what went wrong that's
when the foundation discovered that
there was a different centipede inside
the agent's head where the SCP 378a
instance would typically be it looked
like the foundation had a much bigger
issue on their hand than they ever had
realized the year was
1861 Arthur dupla one of the world's
most renowned explorers and adventurers
hacked through the thick Vines of the
Amazon rainforest with a well-worn
machete he grunted and strained his
clothes heavy and skin slick with sweat
he took a deep Swig from his canteen and
paused briefly to breathe this was the
second week of his solo Expedition into
the lung of the world and the process
had been grueling he'd fought off
piranhas electric eels and invasive
kendrew fish while waiting and kayaking
down the Amazon River he'd contended
with tribesmen and poachers and narrowly
dodged his fair share of poisonous
beasties that could take down prey three
times their size no sane man would Brave
this horror for its own sake but Arthur
has as good a reason as any he was
searching for his younger brother Joseph
dupes who had disappeared a month
earlier during a trek through the Amazon
Joseph had always admired his brother's
Wild Adventures and sought to imitate
him it was for that very reason that
Arthur had felt responsible for his
brother's current predicament and made
it his mission to rescue him the Amazon
is an ancient and cruel mistress the
arrogant and foolish have hoped to
conquer or tame her for centuries but
countless men had disappeared in the
pulsing heart of this green Behemoth
Arthur may have been a worldclass
Explorer in a different League to many
of the others whose lives this Green
Inferno has handedly taken but there
were creatures lurking deep in the
Amazon that went beyond even Arthur's
knowledge the kind of beasts that would
make the darkest and most Twisted
nightmares look comparatively inviting
beasts like SCP
2031 if Joseph was able to send Arthur
one more message before it all came to a
horrible end we could only imagine it'd
be something like don't come for me it's
already too late but there's still time
to save yourself brother stay away for
God's sake stay away you have no idea
what you're dealing with here forget
about me go while there's still time
sadly for Arthur dupes that time was
about to run out he ventured further
into the depths of the Amazon where even
light was scarce under the thick canopy
above a mighty green anaconda slithered
through a nearby tributary tongue
flailing in search of prey an Amazonian
giant centipede a centipede so large and
vicious it prays on snakes and bats
skittered up a nearby Tree on 46
needle-like legs a big meaty tarantula
deafly navigated the branches above
while tree frogs with poison potent
enough to put an entire Army 6 fet under
hoop through the rich undergrowth humans
held no power here Arthur fell to his
knees and began to weep his foolish
Ambitions had gotten his dear brother
killed in this awful Place shot to death
by poachers strangled by anacondas or
eaten alive by vicious bull sharks in
the Amazon River there were so many
horrible ways that Joseph could had died
and in the absence of ever finding a
body all of them would simultaneously be
true the dupes family would never know
peace there would be a void and
emptiness in all of their hearts forever
but just when Arthur was about to give
up hope something miraculous happened he
saw a human figure stumbling around
faintly in the distance Arthur drew his
trusty pistol assuming it could be a
poacher or a hostile tribesman but
something was different the figure had
its back to Arthur but he recognized its
shirt a distinctive shade of light blue
just like the shirt that Arthur had
bought for Joseph on his previous
birthday could it be was it really him
Arthur holstered his weapon and jumped
to his feet he couldn't let this figure
get away even if there was only the
tiniest chance it could actually be his
brother and not some kind of forest
Mirage Arthur ran towards the figure
with the last of his energy reserves
panting and wheezing he called his
brother's name again and again but the
figure didn't respond it just stumbled
along as though drunk but the closer
Arthur got the more certain he was that
this was indeed his brother the height
the hair the clothes the build it was
Joseph dup cease but why wasn't he
responding why wouldn't he turn around
as Arthur finally reached the figure he
grounded to a halt the most profound
sense of dread fell over him like a
sudden Monsoon something unnatural
something truly terrible was about to
happen but he didn't know what and
moreover it was too late to stop now
feeling anxiety prickling up his legs
and back Arthur reached forward to grab
his brother by the shoulder the word
Joseph trembling on his lips when
Arthur's hand touched Joseph's shoulder
he felt a fear greater than anything
he'd experienced before something was
moving beneath the skin of Joseph's
shoulder something rising and Alive a
million tiny creatures all working
together in his brother's flesh before
he could even draw his hand away his
brother turned or rather the creatures
that were wearing his brother's body
turned around Arthur couldn't help but
scream at the horrible sight before for
him his brother's face looked loose and
rotten aging skin hanging off a rotting
skull his jaw hung loose no tongue
inside no eyes either just millions of
ants swarming in and out of Joseph dup's
vacant Dead face the ants were huge and
spiny with long curved mandibles Eon
brelli a particularly hearty species of
New World Army ant Arthur stepped back
babbling in Terror at what had become of
his brother the Joseph suit stepped
forward towards him and almost
instinctively Arthur pushed him with
both hands feeling the nightmarish
activity swarming beneath the loose
cover of Joseph's bony chest the Joseph
suits tumbled backward tripping over a
rock and burst there were no organs left
inside his brother now they'd been eaten
long ago it was just a thin tarpine of
gray skin over dry bones and of course
Millions upon millions of ants now
making a be line for Arthur with the
frightening military Precision any
naturalist could expect from eiton belli
but while army ants could be a
formidable and frightening foe in their
own right nobody had seen any ants like
this before well nobody who'd lived to
tell the tale at least Arthur turned to
flee but sadly it was already too late
for him what he thought were mere
prickles of anxiety were actually an
invasion force of ecton belli soldiers
which had positioned themselves over key
nerves and ligaments on his skin and and
spine as Arthur tried to run away the
ants began to bite into him cutting
through skin rending bone and munching
into the chewing neurons underneath
Arthur felt intense flashes of pain all
over his body before collapsing to the
ground paralyzed that's when the true
Horrors began if there was one
consolation for Arthur in this last
terrible hours of his life he would at
least know firsthand exactly how his
brother died he couldn't move but he
could feel everything the creatures
chewed through the Flesh of his
extremities cutting holes in his skin
and creating openings for swarms of
their insect Brethren to enter through
Arthur felt like he was on fire as the
Swarm entered his body but was unable to
do anything about it death by these
creatures is a slow and torturous
experience unlike their non-anomalous
counterparts the Swarms don't
immediately start devouring all
available soft tissue SCP 2031 wants to
keep their prey alive while they
renovate their new home Arthur finally
died 2 days later from dehydration it
was at this point that the creatures
finally began eating his organs and
eventually Distributing their colony
throughout his body the ants even
produce an enzyme that slows the
decaying process for their deceased
hosts that's why Joseph dupes didn't
look a whole lot worse by the time
Arthur found him even though he'd
already suffered a month of postmortem
infestation not long after Arthur's
death the Arthur suit got up and walked
away the world would never know how or
why Arthur dupes and his brother
disappeared in the dark heart of the
Amazon jungle but perhaps for the sake
of all those who loved them ignorance is
actually Kinder than the truth it would
be almost a century before the
foundation finally discovered these
creatures on a nearby Farm designated
them SCP 2031 and began containment and
testing they soon became aware of what
Arthur Joseph and many others had
learned the hard way while they may be
relatively ineffectual individually
together these insects were a real force
to be reckoned with very few
non-anomalous animals had any chance of
escaping them once they'd set their
sights on a Target and began assuming
their attack positions in one observed
instance SCP 2031 soldiers were able to
take down a 1,000 kg Angus bull in 5
minutes most of which was just spent
getting their soldiers into their proper
positions over the spine and leg
ligaments the foundation just got
extremely lucky that these vicious
insect Predators happened to be isolated
to some pretty specific areas in South
America thanks to the climate
requirements of their habitats in fact
pretty much all of the specimens the
foundation found were all in one place
the creatures had developed a
particularly frightening form of ant
farm known as SCP
231- an isolated containment Zone on a
stretch of Farmland where the ants could
find hosts in the form of live people
and animals keeping them relatively
isolated 27 separate SCP 2031 colonies
were first found on this farm inhabiting
and operating 27 different corpses these
include 15 cows five different horses
three domestic pigs one dog and Most
Fascinating of all three human specimens
an adult male an adult female and a
child of unspecified gender what's even
more fascinating than the efficacy of
these ants and attacking all different
kinds of prey is their deafness and
mimicking the behavior of their hosts
this isn't a reconstructive maggot
situation see our video on that
nightmare for further information the
ants attempt to make their hosts
actually act like the creatures they
once were the foundation were astonished
to see that the three human suits seem
to actually go through the motions of
running the farm watering the livestock
dispensing feed moving other SCP 2031
colonies from one pasture to another the
human child suit would even spend
extensive time playing with the dog suit
engaging in games such as fetch or mock
wrestling how the SCP 2031 colonies are
able to do this is unknown working
theories include rigorous observation of
their targets before colonization and
the colony hive mind somehow picking up
residual thoughts or muscle memory from
their victims nonanomalous ants
introduced to the SCP 2031 colonies also
begin exhibiting anomalous traits so the
effects May somehow be contagious one of
the most fascinating moments of all came
when the structural Integrity of the dog
suit finally gave out leading to its
Colony exiting the body and returning to
more nomadic Behavior typical of army
ants in search of a new host the strange
part was that the human suits actually
seemed to grieve for the deceased dog
suit with the child suit becoming
somewhat distressed that their Playmate
was suddenly gone the two human suits
even took the carcass of the dog suit
and buried it in another pasture it it
was unlike anything the foundation had
observed with SCP 2031 before at what
point did mimicry become sincere
Behavior because now SCP 2031 was
seriously blurring the lines it is in
the best interest of the foundation to
keep this little Ant Farm going both to
keep SCP 2031 distracted from venturing
further and causing trouble and to
further study the fascinating behaviors
and Dynamics exhibited by SCP 2031
colonies in captivity City one of the
researchers has already put in a request
for a new golden retriever our
disgusting tale of anomalous nastiness
begins in the humble town of Beckley
West Virginia back in the
1990s it was 10:00 a.m. on a hot day in
early August as Oscar Doug was winding
his way through the wooded roads and
back streets of town he isn't the
villain of our story he's just a man
doing his very unglamorous job cleaning
up roadkill for the local government
plenty of Woodland Critters meet their
ends against the wheels and bumpers of
careless drivers and it was thanks to
the tireless work of people like Oscar
Doug that the fine roads of Rural
America aren't piled high with carcasses
of course Oscar was used to seeing some
unpleasant things on the job but nothing
like this when he began pulling over to
the side of the Lonely Street to pick up
a dead deer he was shocked to see a
sudden flash of stark white illuminated
by his headlights it was a naked human
woman crouched over the deer carcass she
was sucking at the exposed red flesh on
the deer's flank as though feeding off
of it flies circled around her in the
hot summer air the smell emerging from
the deer carcass was unspeakable but the
woman didn't even seem to care she just
fed away with a crazed look in her eye
and even more disturbing was the fact
that he recognized her it was Mrs Faber
a local eccentric who lived with her
husband on on a farm just outside of
town or at least she had you see Oscar
Doug had never met Mrs Faber in person
before he only recognized her from the
missing person Flyers posted around town
he pulled out his cell phone to call the
authorities when suddenly Mrs Faber was
startled by something and fled into the
woods this would be the first of many
encounters reported by towns F
concerning Mrs Faber or more
specifically the anomalous species that
was once Mrs Faber and is now designated
SCP
726 Mrs Faber practically became a local
crypted similar to that of Sasquatch or
the Loch Ness monster with sightings of
her in the woods and around town
frequently being reported by the locals
of course Mr fa was beside himself about
the whole situation what was happening
to his beloved wife people assumed a
psychotic break or some kind of sudden
onset of acute dementia she had to be
apprehended and brought in for her own
good before she caused harm to herself
or others and on August 16th she was
finally found and captured Mrs fa was
found in the dumpster of a local diner
with a large dog after being subdued she
was sent to a nearby hospital her
condition had seemingly Advanced to the
point where she was no longer even
capable of speech however if it had
ended there the SCP Foundation wouldn't
have been called in it would have just
been a sad local story of a woman who
came very unwell but that was only the
beginning to the true strangeness behind
SCP
726 random Liv stock like cows and pigs
were found across the town behaving
incredibly bizarre exhibiting actions
and traits uncommon of their respective
species and the most shocking of all was
that the sightings of Mrs Faber around
town still didn't stop despite her being
actively held by a local hospital
naturally that's when the SCP Foundation
decided to take control of the situation
they dispatched field agents to properly
investigate and figure out what was
going on in Beckley West Virginia that's
when they discovered A peculiar
commonality maggots you see the behavior
exhibited by the strange animals and by
Mrs Faber was not consistent with their
own species but they were incredibly
consistent with the behaviors of the
common botfly a particularly unpleasant
form of fly that sometimes lays its eggs
in the bodies of still living animals
the anomalously affected entities
exhibited insectoid movements an
affinity for rotting meat and even
strange shifting of the back muscles
suggesting the gesture of flapping wings
that weren't there but what was going on
here was this mind control or something
more Insidious as it turned out the key
to unlocking this mystery was in the
dumpster that Mrs Faber was found in an
entire Pig was found inside the dumpster
exhibiting the same strange Behavior
behaviors as the other anomalous animals
but not long before it was transformed
into a pig it was simply a half-eaten
hot dog thrown to waste in the garbage
this miraculous transformation came
courtesy of SCP
726 now also known as the reconstructive
maggots much like regular maggots these
creatures are attracted to decaying
flesh and will multiply and consume dead
bodies or rotten food rapidly however
the truly strange thing is what happens
afterward
the maggots will expel purified waste
matter which then reconstitutes back
into a kind of living exact clone of the
entity it once was well exact in a
physical sense in a psychological sense
these clones are exactly like a mature
botfly the maggots that reconstitute
these bodies die off almost immediately
but whenever two of these clones mate
with reproductive Behavior often being
inspired by the presence of carcasses or
spoiled meat they produce more eggs
which in turn release SCP 726 maggots
and begin the cycle all over again and
fascinatingly these maggots can
reconstitute an entire clone from even a
portion of the original creature which
begs the question why were there
seemingly multiple Mrs fabers cited in
and around the town of Beckley West
Virginia upon further investigation into
Mrs Faber and her husband a terrible
secret came to life
Mr Faber had murdered his wife in a fit
of rage and cut up her body before
burying the pieces around the grounds of
his home unbeknownst to him an
infestation of SCP 726 maggots across
the property ate each piece and
reconstituted them into individual fly
brained clones of the original Mr Faber
was later arrested for the murder and
multiple people in the town of Beckley
were given amnestic treatment to forget
the strange and frightening things
they'd seen but for the foundation the
strange and frightening things were only
just beginning an unnamed doctor with
the SCP Foundation decided to conduct a
series of utterly repulsive experiments
on SCP 726 opening the log with the
Fateful words I've decided to begin by
testing the limits of repeated
replication a single SCP 726 egg will be
introduced per sample due to their rapid
multiplication maggot volume does not
affect their speed of operation only the
size of the organism to be reconstructed
the first subject was a recently
deceased Norwegian rat cut in half
lengthwise when the SCP 726 eggs were
introduced the two halves were rapidly
constituted into a pair of living rats
with mirrored fur patterns both of these
rats were then ground into a fine paste
and mixed wondering if SCP 726 would
create a hybrid they did not instead
separating the mix into two piles and
once again creating two rats nearly
identical to the ones before except for
one of them now having a red right eye
the rat without the red right eye was
processed into a fine paste get used to
hearing that phrase before the
introduction of more SCP 726 samples it
reproduced a close approximation of the
Rat it once was aside from a slight limp
and blindness in both eyes the heart was
then taken from this rat and upon the
introduction of SCP 726 into to the
heart it was reconstituted without eyes
or any pigmentation a note also mentions
that the creature squeaked incessantly
the heart from this rat was then taken
and cut in half before SCP 726 was
introduced the result was a pair of even
more severely messed up eyess rats one
could only walk in tight circles and the
other immediately attacked the first rat
the doctor noted that both physiology
and insect Behavior seemed to degrade
with repeated reconstitute tions of the
same genetic material next a scrap of
Flesh was taken from the hairless rat
the creature that reconstituted from
this was hairless eyeless and limbless
and didn't successfully survive for long
a liver was found inside its brain case
but because this particular researcher
hadn't spit in the face of God enough
for one day the tests continued the
liver from the brainless rat was given a
dose of SCP 726 and the result was an
eyess leg ESS limbless creature with a
long wormlike midsection which quickly
began to devour its own posterior before
dying of blood loss this dead rat was
then put through three more iterations
of testing it first became a large
formless mass of tissue and then a long
slug-like creature that takes in
nutrients through its skin after this no
more changes were recorded as it had
presumably reached its Peak Performance
the scientists decided to keep this
creature for long-term observation
naming it brundle after the scientist in
David cronenberg's remake of The Fly at
this point the doctor began to conduct
tests that mercifully did not involve
any more rats instead the foundation
moved on to humans dried flesh from a
body that's over 2,000 years old was
given to SCP 726 leading to a full
reconstitution of a middle-aged man with
the mind of a fly opening doors to
potential practical forensic
applications of SCP 26 humans seem to
experience a similar degree of form
degradation after multiple
reconstitutions from the same genetic
material but due to humans being larger
and more complex organisms the changes
are often less pronounced like changes
in eye color or fingerprints while the
forensic use of SCP 726 is an Open Door
clones produced by SCP 726 are worthless
for both medical and food purposes
during one experiment SCP 72 6 was used
to replace a missing chunk of a wounded
DCL class's leg this appeared to be
successful at first until the d-class
later experienced a rapid mental
Devolution into a fly likee State just
like the other victims of SCP
726 the declass was terminated and the
test was recorded as a failure it's
believed that a similar thing would
happen if organ transplants were taken
out ofp 726 clones and given to
nonanomalous donors SCP 726 was used to
clone several livestock animals such as
cows and pigs food items like steaks
were rendered from these animals cooked
and given to D classes much like the
transplants this led to a similar state
of devolution for those who ate the
infected meat even when the meat was
thoroughly disinfected and processed the
anomalous effects remained so no SCP 726
won't be ending world hunger anytime
soon though if it gave us all the minds
of flies through tainted meet it may at
least end all Global Warfare seeing as
flies don't have the mental capacity to
create or wield weapons at this point it
seemed that the researcher was just
curious and felt like trying some other
random experiments just for the heck of
it like getting a SCP 726 to
reconstitute a non-anomalous botfly
leading to the Clone simply being an
unusually large botfly which died
shortly thereafter or testing a burger
patty from a local independent
drive-through restaurant that
reconstituted into two different cows
and one large rat yummy but the most
horrifying result of all came when they
tested SCP 726 on what was supposedly a
vegan burger made entirely out of
artificial meat and plant matter the
resulting creatures were so unimaginably
horrifying they literally cannot be
described even hardened SCP Foundation
researchers were driven to scream and
vomit at the mere sight of them one of
these creatures was killed and ground
into fine Pace before SCP 7 26 was
introduced again somehow this resulted
in something even worse a truly
horrifying unkillable entity on par with
SCP 682 even when they liquefied the
Beast it kept attacking they could only
stop it by freezing it and keeping it on
ice testing into SCP 726 was suspended
shortly thereafter ah maggots botflies
and rat paste how lovely if you were
eating during any of this well you only
have yourself to blame there is a planet
orbiting a g-type main sequence star
unlike the millions of barren rocks
littering the cosmos this one is in what
scientists call The goldilock Zone the
area around a star believed to be most
capable of sustaining life and life does
more than just survive on this world it
thrives the distant world is home to a
mix of animal and plant life including a
large technologically advanced
civilization of humans other than the
Earth Earth this is the most complex
ecosystem the SCP Foundation is aware of
and it may be the greatest threat to
life on Earth in the universe this is
SCP 3003 a ker class object with one of
the most ominous nicknames in the entire
Foundation database the end of History
Research into this world which is
located roughly 208 Lighty years from
Earth revealed many similarities to our
own world it is only 3% heavier than
Earth rotates in 30 hours and orbits its
Sun at a similar distance to our own
Planet the temperatures are similar and
they are tempered enough that the
majority of the planet's land mass is
able to support large numbers of life
forms while few species found on SCP
3003 are identical to those on Earth
many are surprisingly similar but it's
three of these organisms specifically
that combine to create an existential
threat to our own world SCP 33-1 is a
small Beetle like creature known as Mars
by the planet's human population while
they grow to only 3 cm in length at most
they have a strong ability to defend
themselves in addition to their hard
carpas they can shoot a spider silk-like
substance from their abdomen and coat
themselves with acidic liquid which
makes them impossible for predators to
eat they spend most of their time
swarming and feeding on plants and can
live 15 years in the wild they're
largely harmless to the planet's humans
that is until an invisible enemy enters
the picture SCP 33-2 is a single cell
amiea likee creature that has evolved to
be completely dependent on other beings
like the Mars in other words it's a
parasite and SCP 33-1 is essential to
its life cycle after it makes contact
with the Mars and infects them though it
doesn't stick around rather it starts to
transform The Beetles into vicious
parasites themselves causing them to
grow a long pointed Stinger on their
head this Stinger can paralyze its
Target allowing the Mars to inject
whatever it stung with the population of
SCP
33-2 lurking inside of it and these
Beatles that have been taken over only
have one target SCP 33-3 entities are
humans 30 billion of them to be precise
the human civilization of SCP 3003 is
far larger than our own and Studies have
indicated that they're genetically
identical and could even produce viable
Offspring with the humans on Earth and
they are the primary target of the
infection of SCP
33-1 and 2 when attack by the infected
Mars the beetle creates a hole and
enters into the human's body before
sealing the hole with its silk material
once inside it can live up to 3 years
inside the human during which time the
human is fundamentally transformed once
they've been infected the SCP 33-3 human
becomes obsessed with spreading the Mars
and develops a pleasure responds to
being in its presence they maintain
their intelligence and become hyper Ral
able to evaluate information quickly and
effectively without any influence of
emotions while the capacity for emotions
remains these humans rarely Express them
and almost never act on them they have
one primary function to spread the
infection further it sounds like the
beginning of an alien invasion but the
invasion already happened the war is
over and the humans of the planet
orbiting hip
56948 have lost the infection is not
growing it's already complete SCP 3003
has a population of 30 billion humans
and every single one is host to SCP 33-1
parasites this happened centuries ago
and the entire Society has since been
reshaped to accommodate these parasitic
creatures and to make the human
population more hospitable to them while
these humans are identical to those on
Earth they lack its genetic diversity
the humans of SCP 3003 have been
selectively bred to make ideal hosts
complete with larger bodies more fat
tissue higher pain tolerance and less
susceptibility to diseases but the
society has not degraded due to the
infection quite the opposite the SCP
33-3 population has become a hive mind
of sorts working together towards a
single purpose as such these humans have
evolved to be far more united than
humans on Earth they all speak a single
language similar to Dutch with no other
languages still active all humans belong
to the same culture and research has
indicated this is about 500 years old
before the infection they were a humble
society that had over 7,000 different
cultures and mainly engaged in trading
none of them exist anymore and they
aren't the only thing that's gone SCP
3003 lacks Earth's genetic diversity in
animal and plant life that's because in
the early wave of SCP 33-1 infections
the newly infected humans targeted any
species that prayed on the Mars these
mass extinctions created famines and
other ecological catastrophes and led to
a massive change in the way the humans
of SCP 3003 live the vast majority now
live in carefully planned cities built
in the safe and temperate regions of the
planet these cities are mostly enclosed
and are used for industry and food
growth they are also extremely tightly
built so much so that SCP Personnel
reported feeling claustrophobic many
surfaces of the cities are coated with
the material that closely resembles the
feel of SCP
33-1 the Mars Beetle the infected are so
fixated on the pleasure that being
around these beetles gives them that
they use this as a form of entertainment
the remaining members of this society
live in rural areas in small carefully
planned communities dedicated to farming
mining or manufactur facturing these
small pods are even more structured than
the cities children in this world are
raised communally by large groups of
workers specializing in health and
education they are infected quickly at
only a little over a year old which is
as soon as their supervisors are
convinced they're physically capable
once they are infected and their
mindsets converted to the interests of
the Mars the children are quickly tested
to determine their ideal occupation
before being steered into what they will
do for the rest of their life where like
everything else on SCP 3003 their
day-to-day life will be highly
structured adults typically spend 10
hours a day at work with the rest being
spent engaging in basic activities like
eating sleeping attending educational
classes and engaging in entertainment
but the entertainment all revolves
around the society's obsession with SCP
33-1 they listen to recordings of The
Beetles swarms visit the enclosures
where the Beetles are bred or
obsessively touch the distinctive lumps
that the parasite cause on their hosts
everyone fits in on SCP 3003 there is no
other option any sign of Divergence from
one's job function is caused for the
authorities to step in the first step is
medical exams to make sure that the
parasitic infestation isn't becoming too
harmful anyone who doesn't conform to
the social standards is restrained by
local members of The Hive mine and
brought in for observation when someone
becomes too old or sick to work for
society and act as a host for the Mars
their usefulness is at an end and they
are used for organ harvesting and
experimentation in the Society of SCP
3003 one life has no meaning its only
worth is the value it can bring to the
hive mind there's one area of SCP 33's
development that is of Greater concern
to the foundation though their
technology SCP 33-3 works as one and
that has allowed it to develop
technology far beyond that of what we
have on Earth their planet is run almost
entirely on wind solar and tidal power
with a small amount also coming from
geothermal and nuclear their computers
have enough power to produce data that
makes foolproof recommendations for
public policy and their artificial
intelligence systems are far beyond
anything the foundation has developed
their crops have been genetically
modified to have ideal hardiness and
nutritional value and they routinely
experiment on their own DNA for
selective breeding purposes the planet
has launched satellites in to space and
visited the other planets in their solar
system but it's one invention in
particular that has brought this strange
planet to the foundation attention SCP
33-4 is a massive facility on SCP 3003
with one purpose to open wormholes that
can transport members of the planet to
any other point in space each use of
this device uses up more energy than
Earth uses in a full year and the device
seems to have been created with one goal
in mind to trans transport
representatives to other planets that
can expand their parasitic civilization
to the desire to spread the infection of
the Mars is a single-minded Obsession
for the citizens of SCP 3003 and they
now have their sights set on Earth
unlike most dangerous specimens SCP 3003
and its native species were not
discovered in the wild rather it made
contact directly with the Earth through
its Wormhole generator sending
ambassadors who came bearing the news of
their Gospel of a better unified way of
life that would be achieved by joining
their growing Empire they could have
passed for missionaries but what they
were preaching was infection with a
parasitic mutated Beetle the SCP
Foundation was not prepared for this
first Contact and collected all the
evidence they could on this strange new
Society they quickly came up with one
conclusion SCP 3003 was larger more
powerful and more advanced than anything
on Earth even the SCP Foundation found
with no other option available for
containing the threat the foundation
took the only approach they could making
peaceful contact with the ambassadors
and making them think Earth was
interested in what they were offering as
long as the representatives of SCP 3003
think they are involved in peaceful
negotiations for how to introduce the
Mars to Earth they are ready to
cooperate and agree to some of the
foundation's terms this has given the
foundation the opportunity to study the
society and identify some potentially
exploitable weak points and they found
one in particular that may give humans a
chance for survival that weakness the
representatives of SCP
33-3 do not know how to lie once they're
converted to host the Mars everything
they do serves a common purpose and is
shared with every other member of their
Hive likee Society there is no need to
lie and no purpose to it in their
society and as such they can be deceived
far more easily than most humans that
gives the SCP Foundation the chance to
stall them and fool them into thinking
Earth is planning for integration at its
own pace but even the residents of this
strange civilization's patience may have
its limits the representative seemed
Cooperative at first agreeing to many
concessions the foundation requested
including carefully regulating where
they entered Earth and making the
foundation their first point of contact
for their Earth contact and research
committee this allows the foundation to
ensure no invasive species makes their
entry onto Earth unknown because the
civilization is unable to lie the
foundation has convinced them that Earth
is contaminated and unable to host the
Mars with the species becoming sterile
when introduced the representatives seem
to believe this and believe they are
working on a solution with Earth but
some members of SCP
33-3 may be becoming more aggressive it
was after a meeting with a
representative of SCP 3003 that
Foundation researcher Dr Shaw entered an
elevator with the alien
suddenly the mared host became enraged
tearing the control panel out of the
wall and stopping the elevator Dr Shaw
was terrified but the representative
simply said it wanted some alone time
the SCP 33-3 representative started
speaking but it didn't seemed to speak
like the other members it was intense
and intimidating and most worrying it
referred to taking over a two-legged
species over 500 years ago it wasn't the
human speaking but neither was it the
mark
no this was the single cell organism
that had puppeteered both them and the
Mars unlike the humans of SCP 3003 it
wasn't fooled by the foundation
subterfuge it knew they were resisting
and it didn't believe the story about
the planet being inhospitable to the
Mars it wanted the Earth to surrender
and join the hive mind and it argued
Earth would be better for it no more war
no more conflict no more hate no more
poverty all it would take was the
complete surrender of everyone on
Earth's Free Will and it made clear that
it would win it would be the last thing
the only thing left in the universe and
everyone would join it one way or
another it was clear that the threat of
SCP 3003 was more pressing than thought
which posed a question how do you
contain an entire planet the decision to
classify SCP 3003 as ker wasn't hard but
none of the foundation's other tactics
they'd Ed in the past would apply here
investigation into the capabilities of
the planet made clear that if a war was
to break out between the two planets it
would end swiftly and decisively in
favor of SCP 3003 if the SCP 33-2 living
inside the bloodstream of the planets
humans were aware of the foundation's
deceptions they did not seem to be
letting the humans of their planet in on
this so the deception would hold for now
but SCP 3003 was moving fast as well and
soon it might be too late to contain it
two projects in particular concern the
foundation one is a genetic tampering
experiment to make SCP 33-3 more
hospitable to their purpose it would add
artificial genes to their human hosts
making them consume less resources
becoming immune to Common pathogens and
making them able to host 10 times as
many Mars inside their bodies these
genes would turn the infected humans
into their own new species they are
working on travel two and terraforming
planets in other star systems which
would make them capable of spreading
virtually anywhere and at that point
impossible to contain but the foundation
has some last ditch plans in motion to
stop this in addition to continuing
their disinformation campaign and the
ongoing Research into samples of the
Mars and the Single Cell being that
mutates them the foundation is preparing
for the worst case scenario too they are
spreading disinformation among
scientists to ensure no additional
contact is made with elements outside
the SCP Foundation and the 05 Council
has authorized studies into how to
eliminate this threat permanently but
the foundation will only have one chance
to do so and any attempt will need to
involve the elimination of their
Wormhole device to keep them from
escaping because even one specimen
escaping could mean infestation of
another world and eventually the threat
would begin a new but for now the
foundation has not deemed any plans for
an attack to neutralize SCP 3003 either
practical or likely to succeed which
means the foundation is left focusing on
maintaining stable relations with SCP
33-3 they continue to try and convince
them that the Earth is moving towards
peaceful integration and let's hope they
succeed in this task for as long as they
can because for now this is the only
thing we have standing between us and
the end of History take a brief moment
to think back to your young younger
years spending long tiresome hours
trapped in a classroom waiting to hear
the noise of that final Bell of the day
that sound meant Freedom the end of
another grueling 6 hours at your desk
and the chance to get back to the warm
sanctuary of home if you were lucky you
might not have had to go far to get back
to the Safety and Security of being in
your parents' house living close enough
to the school would mean you could
easily walk home when the day was
through but your classmates well they
weren't all as lucky some of them had
miles to travel all the way across town
even fortunately though the school bus
would always be waiting outside at the
end of each day ready to take a gaggle
of rowdy kids back home and if you were
one of those kids that had to take the
bus you'll know that the trip home after
school was hardly a calm drive paper
planes and spitballs firing from all
directions wads of chewing gum stuck to
the undersides of seats other kids all
around you screaming and yelling at the
top of their lungs still it could be
worse right no trust us it could be much
much worse than you can ever imagine
what if one day the bus that picked you
up from school wasn't a bus at all what
if instead it was SCP
2086 picture this one day you get put in
detention at school maybe you were
disrupting a class or were caught
spraying graffiti on the outside wall of
the gym whatever the reason we're sure
you'll think it is unfair that you got
held back after school after everyone
else had already gone home but you do
your time until finally you're told you
can leave problem is your house is on
the other side of town and you've
already missed the bus you make your way
off the campus down the nearest Street
maybe there's a city bus you can catch
that'll get you back home as you stroll
away from your school you realize that
the nearest bus stop the first one on
the route home seems to be further away
than you remember it being must be just
the exhaustion of a long day getting the
better of you playing tricks on your
mind it's not like someone could move
the bus stop right finally reaching the
stop you notice lights coming down the
street after a few moments of waiting
quietly a late bus just like you hoped
for it pulls up to the next stop the
doors folding open to allow you on board
it's totally empty save for the driver
but straight away you notice there's
something odd about him he seems drained
of color his movements are weird
more like a puppet on strings than an
actual living breathing human being now
that you think about it if it wasn't for
the fact he was clearly moving driving
the bus you might assume that he was a
corpse then again maybe he just had a
long day too taking a seat you try not
to think about it and stare out of the
window in boredom you watch as the route
takes you past stop after stop all of
them empty just like the bus itself but
then something unexpected happens you've
ridden the bus to and from school so so
many times before that you can't help
but notice when for some reason it takes
a wrong turn looking out the window you
know you aren't mistaken the driver has
changed Direction instead of heading
towards the nearest Stop to home he's
taken the bus towards the furthest Edge
of Town desperately you try yelling at
him asking why he's taking the wrong
turn but the driver stays still as if he
can't even hear what you're saying
that's when you notice the smell you
didn't catch it before but now it's all
around you filling the air inside the
bus it's almost like the scent of
disinfectant the bus now smells the same
way a hospital does but that's not all
the more you breathe it in the more you
feel yourself starting to get woozy arms
and legs getting heavier everything
around you feels as if it's spinning
uncontrollably out of the windows you
can just about make out the sight of a
junkyard blurring in and out of focus
it's meant to be abandoned and and yet
you're sure you can see movement massive
indeterminate shape shifting around in
the dark finally your vision goes dark
and you fall unconscious onto the floor
of the bus only you were never on the
bus to begin with no although you didn't
know it you were prey to something that
just looked like a bus SCP
2086 and now that it's caught you you'll
never see the light of day again now SCP
2086 doesn't just refer to a single
creature not by a long shot it is the
designation given to an entire species
of arthropods think lobsters crabs and
spiders or insects like centipedes and
millipedes only much bigger to the
untrained eye and depending on when you
look an instance of SCP 2086 will
normally look like any ordinary public
transport vehicle of any make and model
or belonging to any company or Transit
Authority usually though they look like
regular old buses at least while they're
out foraging for food when born an SCP
2086 specimen will grow to full juvenile
size within a week usually weighing 200
kg or less full matured adult instances
however can weigh approximately 177,000
kg the adults are the ones that go out
foraging leaving the nest to collect
food to then bring back to the juvenile
SCP 286s and by food we of course mean
humans while out on the roads matured
SCP 2086 creatures are practically
identical to the auto vehicles that form
their bodies but the materials that this
disguise is made from the steel plastic
wood and glass they're all actually
comprised of specialized kiten the kind
of outer shell you'd find on most
arthropods but underneath that outer
shell that's where you'll find the Real
Horror within the main chamber beneath
the flooring of the bus's long inner
portion is stored the pulsing Beating
Heart of an SCP 2086 specimen and we
don't mean that in a metaphorical sense
if you were to lift up the floorboards
of one of these bus-like creatures you'd
see its heart along with other vital
organs like the creature's brain and
stomach what's more the figure in the
front seat that you thought was a living
breathing bus driver actually isn't
living or breathing not anymore
preserved in a shellock substance that
the creature is able to produce the
driver is actually a human corpse acting
as a Decoy for SCP 286s from within the
bus body fibrous appendages reach up
into the corpse almost like incredibly
thin hairs the creature can then use the
caver essentially as a puppet a puppet
with a dead person's body that's how an
SCP 2086 is able to move its driver
around making it appear more lifelike so
it can lure its prey aboard think of it
like the bioluminescent light that an
angler fish uses to tempt unsuspecting
fish into their jaws same principle but
with a dramatically different result
when it comes to SCP 2086 but if you
thought bus creatures with internal
organs under the floor and Dead Meat
Puppets in the driver's seat weren't
creepy enough there's still much more to
SCP 286s than meets the eye for example
when they aren't out foraging the adult
creatures can unravel the roof of their
bus-- shaped outer shell underneath is a
pair of wings large enough and strong
enough to carry their entire 7,000 kilos
of weight off the ground and up into the
air as For Eyes the headlights at the
front are in actual fact bioluminescent
Optical organs allowing the creatures to
see their prey even in the dark still
not horrifying enough well would knowing
about their legs help the wheels
underneath an SCP 2086 specimen are also
capable of unraveling forming long gray
or black legs like those of a spider yes
these are bus creatures with wings and
multi-jointed legs these legs aren't
just big clumsy appendages either
compared with other arthropods SCP 286s
are able to use their limbs to perform
surprisingly intricate actions and finer
levels of manipulations for instance a
number of specimens have been observed
in the Wild by the SCP Foundation
Building shelters out of any materials
that they can find near their nesting
ground and where do they normally Nest
wherever there's plenty of scrap metal
and hardly any people to notice them
junkyards are the preferred habitats of
SCP 286s and where they will normally
EST establish their colonies while the
juveniles remain within the confines of
the colony adult SCP 2086 specimens will
leave to collect humans although on
occasion the younger specimens have been
known to travel out from their nest and
rearrange or relocate signposts for bus
stops they then place them in a route
that leads them back towards their
nesting ground it's something worth
remembering if your nearest bus stop
ever seems to be a little further away
from the school than usual afterward the
older specimens will travel along the
Route laid out by the juvenile SCP 286s
picking up any human passengers that
they find waiting at the relocated bus
stops they have to choose their moments
wisely with people boarding and
disembarking from the bus usually every
few stops once an SCP 2086 has as many
humans on board as it can carry with the
certainty it won't lose any at the
upcoming stop it secretes a substance
similar to chloroform this fills the
inner chamber of the bus causing that
noxious smell like Hospital disinfectant
the chloroform like substance
incapacitates all the passengers on
board rendering them unconscious and
readying them to be taken back to the
local SCP 2086 Colony once the adult SCP
2086 has arrived at the junkyard the
juveniles will descend on it given their
much much smaller size they will climb
inside the mature specimen and forcibly
remove each and every human passenger it
is carrying within then comes the truly
nasty part feeding time each juvenile
SCP 2086 will force their captive human
through an orifice that is located under
the front hood of their vehicle's shell
this sphincter a circular formation of
muscle that can expand and contract to
perform a bodily function is connected
to where the steering wheel is found on
an adult SCP 2086 the younger creatures
will push their human prey through the
sphincter consuming them once this has
occurred those hairy appendages in the
driver's seat will then latch onto the
body of the now dead human piercing
through their skin winding up and around
their bones these are the same fibrous
hairs used to puppet the deceased corpse
and use it to lure others aboard the bus
but these appendages have another
function their feeding tubes they will
drain every last drop of blood from the
sccp 2086 is prey until the body is
little more than a husk at which point
the tubes inject a saline solution
directly into the cadaver afterwards the
inside of the bus fills with that same
substance that preserves the corpse and
the process is complete as horrifying as
these creatures are one of the few
upsides of SCP 286s is that they don't
live very long female specimens will
reproduce after 8 days and produce 20
Offspring after this point each of these
newborns reaches full maturity and size
in about a week on average SCP 286s live
for 12 to 15 days another net positive
is because of their short lifespans an
SCP 2086 specimen doesn't need to feed
on a human more than once as the
nutrients it absorbs as a juvenile are
enough to sustain it through adulthood
once it has matured an SCP 2086 will go
out into the nearest city or town to
forge for humans providing food to the
Next Generation and so the cycle
continues in the future rather than
taking the bus maybe it's safer to walk
it might mean the difference between you
making it home or becoming food now and
again you might stumble across an entry
in the SCP Foundation Arch that is far
more than meets the eye as you are
probably already aware sometimes the
foundation's numerical SCP designations
can be referencing an entity a creature
an object a location or even a
combination of linked anomalies all
sharing a version of the same number
such is partially the case with SCP
4812 in this instance the designation
number 4812 doesn't refer to One
Singular item or entity in instead it is
more of a collective designation an
umbrella term for three distinct
separate but connected anomalies we've
got a lot of ground to cover here so
without further Ado let's take a look at
SCP 4812 better known collectively as
wrath we'll begin in a cavern deep
beneath Alys in the south of France
where we find the first of the entities
to share the designation SCP
4812 this creature large and without its
own own distinct form is referred to as
SCP 4812 DS it possesses a number of
long appendages that protrude from its
amorphous body each one covered in a
sticky adhesive a sort of glue-like
substance in addition each appendage as
well as the rest of SCP 4812 DS's body
is covered in fine hair that is also
hydrophobic meaning that it does not
absorb water and in fact actively repels
it these tendrils extend deep into the
walls of the cavern surrounding the
creature SCP 481 12-s also has an
inherent latent ability to affect anyone
that visually perceives it in other
words look upon this creature at your
own Peril and we don't mean that looking
at it will drive you mad the fact is
that nobody has been able to look
directly at this creature without
suffering a horrific Grizzly death upon
taking even the quickest glimpse of SCP
4812 DS
the person observing will suffer the
same effect they would if their eyes
brain and entire nervous system had been
dipped in costic acid yes this creature
instantly melts down on a molecular
level anyone who is brave enough or
foolish enough to directly look at it
that means a pain unlike any you could
imagine bleeding through the skin and
all orifices paralysis asphixiation and
then death in that order humans cannot
directly interact with the creature
unless it is submerged in total darkness
where they cannot perceive it visually
the anomalous Hazard of this entity even
extends to photos or video recordings of
SCP 4812 DS however the effect is not as
immediate or violent when someone just
looks at an image or video of it still
you might want to check that your brain
isn't melting after this video is over
just to be safe Beyond killing anyone
that sees it SCP 4812 DS does very
little staying quite still in its cave
behind the maximum security doors the
foundation has put in place at the
entrance so that's our first of the SCP
481 12s who's next how about SCP
4812 an approximately 15 M tall humanoid
made of platinum this entity appears
vaguely skeletal with traces of tungsten
and other metal compounds in its
composition SCP 4812 remains at a
constant body temperature of.
000031 Kelvin or almost
460° F however this entity can also
absorb the heat around it without
changing its own temperature reducing a
cell at room temperature to absolute
zero in around 16 seconds flat and it's
because of this that SCP 4812 D is often
surrounded by a layer of frozen air and
water much like the other creature it
shares a designation with close
interactions with SCP 4812 - e are often
deadly stand too close and the air
around you would drop in temperature
rapidly the water within your body would
freeze and in seconds you would die even
with the use of a specially insulated
suit you would be lucky to gain a few
short moments of added protection the
only thing that weakens SCP 4812 D's
effect is to expose it to extreme heat
although this does not stop the
temperature absorption entirely just
slows it but it's through the constant
application of high temperatures that
the foundation has been able to keep SCP
4812 contained in a thermally controlled
Vault kept intensely hot at all times
finally we have the last of the three
designated as SCP 4812 DK and we
recommend anyone with a bug phobia to
look away now this creature is an
enormous winged insect almost like a
cross between a stag beetle and a
scorpion in some of the physical traits
it shares with them while its size might
be significantly bigger measuring 180 M
long the insect possesses two large
Pinchers four legs four wings that
extend from its back and a long
segmented tail with a pointed Barb at
the tip yes this creepy Crawley would
need a lot more than just a can of raid
to get rid of it but perhaps most
strangely of all his SCP 4812 DK's face
not the typical insect eyes and mouth
you would expect but the face of a human
male much like its Cavern dwelling
counterpart SCP 4812 DK tends to not do
all that much when left alone it can
usually be found flying through the
upper Stratosphere only really moving
when it flaps its wings you might have a
hard time trying to spot it though as
its body is coated in reflected kiten in
other words the bug's exoskeleton
refracts light away from it and makes it
almost invisible while the SCP
Foundation has made attempts to secure
and contain this gigantic flying insect
after they learned of its existence the
creature sheer size and strength have
destroyed any fighter jets or drones
they have sent after it it seems
impervious to damage from Conventional
Weapons with anything fired at it being
almost perfectly reflected and directed
back towards the shooter all the
foundation can really do is hope that
nobody else spots it and keeps a close
eye on SCP 4812 dask through regular
surveillance above all though one
procedure remains consistent and all the
utmost importance with every aspect of
SCP
4812 never under any circumstances can
any of them be allowed to interact with
the other two so what could possibly
connect these three creatures an
amorphous entity that kills anyone who
looks at it a giant humanoid male made
of platinum that alters temperature
without absorbing heat and a winged
insect that is almost perfect at
reflecting anything around it they all
seem to be pretty disconnected yet their
Common Thread must be be pretty
significant for all three to share the
title of SCP 4812 indeed if they had no
relation to each other they could each
have their own unique number and what is
the mysterious fourth redacted entity
that is also referred to as SCP
4812 the answers to this multitude of
questions aren't exactly straightforward
still there does exist a series of
anomalous documents and items that the
foundation has recovered that features
some of the necessary information
recovered from Marcus deis a Dutch
collector of anomalous artifacts these
items are referred to as the conington
set named after Winston J conington an
English archaeologist and a cultist
whose research led the foundation to the
discovery of a number of scps among the
various artifacts of the conington set
is a journal kept by conington himself
featuring depictions of the different
SCP 4812 creatures and notes recording
his findings the set also features three
Hefty tomes written in German over the
course of many years that contain
multiple archaic coordinates in one an
addition in Italian by another author
seems to shed a little light on SCP 4812
the translation of this section tells of
an ancient Kingdom respected above all
others known either as the house of
apolon or the sky Kings of Old Europe
the first ruler of this kingdom was
allegedly a descendant of the king of
Crimson Skies or ASM the first man these
Sky Kings ruled over what is now
modern-day Europe for a 100 Generations
conquering all who opposed them among
their adversaries were those faithful to
the iron God presumably the mechanites
the ancient machine worshipping religion
that preceded the Church of the broken
God eventually however complacency
reared its ugly head and Sky King sarus
VII Von Napoleon looked beyond the
Realms of men hoping to find new land to
conquer sarus VII assembled his forces
the largest army ever seen and set his
sights on the the lands of the fair folk
more commonly known as fairies nowadays
these Fair folk were already engaged in
conflict with their southern neighbors
the children of the Moon and were
drastically underprepared for sars's
approaching forces within 2 weeks the
fairies were scattered driven from their
lands there was however a sole survivor
a fay princess who was captured and
faced the Grim fate of being taken as a
trophy but the princess had other plans
while being taken back to the Sky King's
domain she cast a curse upon the house
of apolon and sarus VII in particular a
horrific storm swept the returning ships
as the Fay princess prayed to an ancient
nameless God for vengeance against her
people's conquerors according to Legend
the change that had her Shackled to
sars's ship caught fire and the blaze
spread until it had burned the Sky
King's ship to Ash it has even been said
that the same chains then wrapped around
SARS himself dragging him down into the
ocean STS
then to defend against any further dark
magic from the remaining Fair folk sarus
the 9th appointed Four Kings to defend
his kingdom by now you might still be
wondering what any of this has to do
with SCP 4812 but don't worry we're
getting there we promise so as the story
continues the remaining ships were still
able to bring the F princess back and
she was brought before sars's air SARS
the 9th Von aoleon who imprisoned her
for what she had done the princess was
sent into to a sealed dungeon deep
beneath the oceans this prison is
heavily implied to be the first of the
SCP 4812 entities better known to us as
SCP 4812 DS however the explanations of
the heatsync Platinum humanoid and the
reflective flying insect are a little
harder to decipher from Winston J
connington's Journal While most of
connington's notes are written in a
cipher a few sections have been
translated according to him from her
prison deep below the Earth the voice of
the Fairy Princess was able to
communicate with the souls of the Four
Knights protecting sarus the 9th's
kingdom as a result the Sky King was
forced to banish them and this brought
forth what conington referred to as the
great profanities without the knight's
defense some Force known as the VIN
venex the first profanity was able to
cast its cold hand over Sarah's only
daughter killing her a creature whose
presence can drain the heat from a
person sounds an awful lot like SCP 4812
huh in retaliation for his daughter's
death Sarah Drew up an ancient spear
called the Godless Lance and struck the
being down casting it into the Earth's
molon core and subduing SCP 4812 D with
the intense heat below another section
describes the king of many faces llant
the creature we know as SCP 4812 DK
connington's findings describe this
entity Slaughter of the DEA a
neighboring Kingdom the enormous insect
appeared from the space beyond spaces
and would deflect perfectly any attack
made against it before taking the faces
of the deava and returning to the skies
but there was one final profanity known
only as the profane dark The Legend
Continues with this profanity a dark
black smear rising from the graves of
the fair folk it soaked through the
Earth and burst From Below claiming the
Sky King and dragging him into the
endless void as it pulled him away sarus
cursed the profane dark cing at Yash the
last great foe of man watching his
kingdom fall without the protection of
His Four Knights all the Sky King could
utter was one repeated word breath the
year is
1941 and the world is gripped by the
most violent and widespread war in
history Millions march to War as bloody
battles are fought across the globe
horrendous atrocities are carried out on
groups of people and parts of London are
bombed to Rubble on a weekly basis
considering it's only been 20 years
since the last World War it must seem to
the early residents of the early 20th
century that the world is coming apart
at the seams and amongst the chaos it'd
be easy not to notice a secluded Manor
House in the English Countryside
disappearing Without a Trace for 11 days
before suddenly returning to our reality
but thankfully one organization makes it
its sole duty to notice the unnoticeable
and understand the impossible the CP
foundation and within that anomalous
manor house foundation agents and
researchers were about to find Horrors
Beyond even their darkest
imaginations this is the Grim tale of
SCP
1461 better known as The House of the
worm when the manor house reappeared
after its 11-day absence the foundation
zeroed in sending agents inside to
investigate it was a two-level dwelling
complete with 12 bedrooms four four
baths three studies a main foyer SL
Ballroom a library a kitchen and a
pantry basement the foundation observed
that a number of these rooms had been
fitted with rows of bunk beds similar to
a boarding house or Barracks only later
would they understand why they found
that the upper portion of the home
exhibited no abnormal qualities
whatsoever but as the agents
investigated further they found an
entrance to the truly anomalous portion
of the manor the extensive subl system
no previous records of the building kept
by the local Council indicated that
there would be anything below the
manner's basement so either the
mysterious previous occupants who were
nowhere to be found had built this
sublevel or had just appeared here on
its own regardless of which was the case
agents and researchers knew that
whatever had happened down here had
everything to do with the manner's
mysterious disappearance they descended
into the depths of what seemed like a
man-made cave system constructed
primarily from a mix of concrete iron
and Brass it was a behemoth of 20th
century technology intricate snaking
systems of pipes gears and pumping
Pistons it was like someone had built an
entire Factory down here but for what
the agents began to spread out through
the Labyrinthian vowels of the manor
hoping to find some answers but all they
seemed to discover was more questions
this place hadn't been built with any
form of comprehensible logic it was full
full of dead ends stairways that
ascended and descended to Nowhere doors
that would open to reveal just walls
behind them or not open at all it was
like a maze built by a maniac it didn't
help that it looked like the place was
recently hit by an earthquake with some
passages caved in and mangled Machinery
strewn about it seemed that no human
workers had interfered with the
impossibly complex and bizarre Machinery
in quite some time a number of the
materials used to construct said
Machinery as well as the gray sandstone
Stone filling in the collapsed
passageways remain unidentified to this
day already the suble was proving to be
a complex puzzle box with only an
estimated 75% of its layout ultimately
being mapped by Foundation researchers
however they would soon realize that
this place wasn't just confusing it was
deadly the only method of
self-maintenance detected by the
exploring agents were pipes that would
fire a thick black lubricant onto the
surrounding Machinery one of the
foundation agents had The Misfortune of
getting covered in it while exploring a
darkened passageway and 80% of his body
was melted as a result it appeared that
the viscous black goo was incredibly
corrosive to all organic matter a number
of the machines also emitted dangerously
High quantities of gamma and x-ray
radiation making it difficult to explore
many of the caverns without heavy Hazmat
protection and worst of all were the
extremely hostile creatures living in
the caves who would regularly attack
Foundation Personnel these Abominations
came Nam to be known as SCP
14611 vicious SteamPunk Frankenstein
monsters once human but with large parts
of their bodies replaced by crude
mechanical implants including metal
teeth and Claws 1461 d1s have displayed
a taste for human flesh and they have
dragged multiple Foundation agents down
into their layer to be converted into
monsters like them it's believed that
SCP 1461 is capable of controlling these
bees through the Strate iic use of sound
from its brass speaking pipes leading
them into areas where Foundation
Personnel are present to instigate
conflict many of these pitiful creatures
have had their throats replaced by
photographs endlessly repeating the same
nonsense phrases over and over again I
am what you have made me I am choice and
I am tyranny forgive me I am then and I
am now what gods they will be then I am
evil and I am flesh I am the Trap I am
Beauty and I am chaos children are
selfish I am the worm I have broken God
still in spite of The Mazes monsters and
deadly chemicals the agents persisted
and managed to discover several
important locations the gel production
chamber on suev 3 creates glass jars
from the unidentified sandstone and
fills them with a slime that looks to
contain living eyes and teeth the
factory deliveries room is filled with a
huge number of crates and boxes which
seem to shift and change in number
between Foundation patrols the speaking
tube room on sublevel 11 contains a
grand Pulpit that acts as the Connecting
Point for the complex array of speaking
tubes running through the entire Cave
System the body parts of a deceased
female also appear to be wired into the
Machinery like spare parts and on
sublevel 12 they found the so-called
Catalyst room here they discovered a
huge complicated Clockwork and steam
powered machine that appeared to be
broken and missing some parts most
horrifying of all though is the raised
platform in the center of the catalst
room on top of which is a metal hospital
bed a desiccated male corpse rests upon
the bed its chest punctured by large
syringes connected by tubes to some kind
of pumping machine the parts connecting
this pumping machine to the overall
apparatus of the room were missing
though leaving its purpose a mystery the
foundation assumed that fluids used to
be Dr out of this corpse to somehow
power the machine you may be starting to
worry that there doesn't seem to be any
answers here that this house is one big
mystery but lucky for you you're wrong
an old Journal was also discovered in
the Catalyst room and if what was
written inside is to be believed then we
may finally have some truth about who
created The House of the worm why it was
created and what horrible events
triggered its mysterious disappearance
and reappearance his true name has been
been redacted by the foundation and
special efforts have been made to
maintain secrecy around the house seeing
as it's an anomaly of great interest to
a cult known as the Church of the broken
God so we'll just call the one who made
this place the inventor before any of
this the inventor was one of the many
Englishmen traumatized and almost killed
in the horrific trench battles of World
War I after a near-death experience the
inventor like many Geniuses and madmen
was plagued by surreal and nightmarish
Visions he saw a huge creature that he
referred to as the worm a gigantic metal
monstrosity with dragon-like Jaws full
of nashing Gears that Rampage through
Europe destroying and devouring
everything in its path these apocalyptic
Visions also presented him with a
solution vague blueprints for a machine
that might be the salvation of him and
others willing to take his new gospel to
heart and escape from a world that the
inventor knew in his heart was about to
end he hired work starve laborers from
across the country to help him make his
Visions a reality and began a massive
secret construction project beneath his
isolated country manor house for the
inventor it was all a labor of love he
wanted to protect his wife son and
daughter from the terrible jaws of the
Worm but as the project stretched on his
wife began to suspect that he'd lost his
mind many of his workers however felt
just the opposite they became infatuated
by the invent sermons on the nature of
the worm and the coming apocalypse they
hoped to escape soon enough they had
become a Bonafide cult constructing the
elaborate sublevels underneath the house
in preparation for the fast approaching
Day of Reckoning then came World War II
the inventor saw Hitler hungry for War
as one of the avatars of the worm
finally knowing that the time was right
he activated the machine and
successfully trapped the worm in the
bowels of his mechanized home however as
the blitz r raged and London's bombing
began the inventor felt as though he
hadn't stopped anything he realized once
and for all that he was never meant to
stop the apocalypse only Escape it and
by throwing the final switch and setting
the machine he and his followers had
built into overdrive he did just that
this was the moment that the house of
the worm disappeared transporting the
inventor his family and his devoted
staff to a different world an empty gray
World devoid of War but also lacking all
the Comforts of regular life including
food things went downhill from there as
their supplies quickly began to run out
and the cult descended into cannibalism
in order to survive things weren't going
much better in the inventor's personal
life his wife fearing what would happen
to the family took her own life and the
life of his daughter though by this
point the inventor's mind was so
fractured that it's possible he may have
killed them himself either way it was
only the inventor and his son left and
more trouble was brewing udora one of
the staff trapped in the building with
the inventor and his cult started a
mutiny she claimed the worm spoke to her
from below and that their only path to
Salvation was pleasing the worm how
would they please it a sacrifice of
course they would give it the son of the
man who had trapped it the mutineers
took the inventor's only remaining child
and descended into the lowest Su levels
the inventor followed hoping to track
them down save his son and Salvage
something from this nightmare as he
ventured deeper battling the members of
eudora's new cult he found that they
were changing themselves becoming the
half-human cyborg creatures that the
foundation would later discover the
inventor would find udora herself in the
speaking tube room her body still living
was wired into the machinery and she had
sacrificed his son to the worm in a rage
the inventor murdered udora or whatever
was left of her then heard a familiar
voice speaking out of a nearby speaking
tube it said I am what you have made me
I am then and I am now I am choice and I
am tyranny I am evil and I am flesh I am
Beauty and I am chaos I am the worm the
voice was his own in that terrible
moment the inventor realized that the
worm wasn't a giant all devouring
monster it was him in trying to protect
his loved on from a perceived apocalypse
he brought them all to their horrible
demise he' trapped them with the monster
he'd hoped for them all to escape from
because no matter what you build you can
escape from who you are grief stricken
and broken the inventor descended into
the Catalyst room there was his son
stuck with the syringes drained of all
life to fuel the Mighty Machine his
father had created in his last moments
the inventor decided to do the only
Noble thing he threw himself into the
machine destroying both it and himself
in the process the house was transported
back to our own reality but the worm in
a sense was no more but who knows if the
worm is really dead its thoughts and
poisonous intent still lingers in the
caverns and rattles through the speaking
pipes whatever really happened the
foundation is still picking up the
pieces today and who knows what lurks in
the parts still hidden from our
knowledge now go check out SCP 082
Ferdinand the cannibal and SCP 2935 o
death for more fascinating freaky files
from the foundation